I don't want to be a first adopter.
Was fucking thing's gonna.
Fall apart.
Boom.
Joe Diaz end with live.
Oh Shit.
Did you really go out and buy one of
those iphones last night?
Did you order?
No,
red band called me and he goes,
are you going to get.
Because I asked them a few.
We call everybody.
I went to get the out,
you know,
I don't know anything about computers,
so I call Redman.
He's my computer guy.
So I went to get the IPAD,
the big one,
the 19.
And I asked the lady because my phone's
fucked up already because just wait for
the eight.
So I called red band about a month ago.
He goes,
wait,
and last night he called out of the
blue.
He goes,
you got to get online at midnight.
And I didn't get it like an asshole.
I just forgot my coat.
I got through,
I got through the second click,
click,
boom.
A water already awarded the silver,
black,
Bam,
Bam.
And then at the end that had to get the
fucking code for I.
I turned a handful.
I woke my wife up in the middle of the
night,
so get the fuck out of here because she
really did tell him to get the fuck out
of here.
You fucking crazy waking me up at 12.
15 stupid fucking phone is going to be
lines around the block and those apple
stores.
It's.
It's crazy.
It's like those sneaker lines.
When you see those people out to buy
sneakers,
supreme lines.
Now supreme has got a whole thing with.
Can they wait in line for three or four
days now and almost almost weekly,
but I'll show you the shit.
You're probably going to freak out when
I show you what they're waiting.
Please do a shovel's bricks with just
the word supreme written on it.
Shovels and bricks t shirts are the main
thing.
Exactly.
It's a brand.
It's a street wear brand
and people wait in line for bricks.
Fucking kids today.
This is what happens when kids don't go
outside.
They don't play,
don't play sports,
and they stay at home.
They just play video games.
Nancy Reagan's fault with the.
Just say no,
he's kids smoked dope.
They see life for what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm going to wait in line for an hour
for fucking break liquors.
This supreme crowbar,
they sell it
boss or the crowbar.
I would just have like the name supreme
on it.
Okay,
well who's using that?
No one uses it.
It's like a.
it's real.
You have to look into the brand a little
bit to understand it,
but it's sort of part of the joke
almost.
They're making parody of the craziness
of it all by just throwing their brand
name on stuff and people are buying into
it.
Go back to the page.
So supreme what the top 10 don wearable
supreme products.
Jesus Christ,
they have fire extinguishers joke,
but some of the clothes are cool nun
chucks.
It just depends.
I mean you got to be really into it and
some people are really into,
like I said,
they wait in line for days.
A lot of them though are making money
off of it because they can buy it for 40
or 50 bucks and flip it for $200.
I don't understand like why is everybody
buying limited,
limited quantities and whatnot,
but what is the big deal about supreme.
Okay.
Cut.
You have to look into the history of.
There's some youtube videos.
You can look up.
You sound
like Eddie Bravo,
gotta look into it.
It's really hard to explain and I like
can't even take me a half an hour to get
into it.
I don't want to hijack the show about
supreme right now.
So I just,
I never,
I wasn't aware of this.
I thought it was just like a tee shirt.
It's where it's dark and you.
So Josh Martin where he spends a lot of
money.
He's a fool.
Well,
he wears those Goddamn yeezys that you
were to spend that much money.
I'm getting for retail.
I wouldn't buy them otherwise.
Josh Martin is like into every trendy
thing.
Everything that comes out.
He's like way ahead of the curve.
The supreme target on the.
Exactly.
Jesus Christ.
Joey,
I don't give a fuck.
I didn't know about this.
You buy a hammer says supreme on it.
The fact they sell nunchucks.
It's hilarious.
Supreme nunchucks.
Did we wait on line when we were kids?
Not for anything.
Like last night I was watching
something,
the real story about the godfather and
they showed when they released the
Godfather,
but New York and that will lines for the
movies.
The movies.
I'm sure I waited in line to go see star
wars,
but not in three fucking days.
Camped out the night before?
No,
not for a hammer.
What did they camp out for back then?
It kept that for something really.
Like the first I ever saw it was a
iphones.
When the first iphone were out,
I remember going to the mall and going,
what in the fuck am I seeing?
And there was a giant line outside the
apple store and this was like one.
One of the first iphone was coming out
and I was like,
why are you waiting for a phone?
You don't have a phone already.
Is this the only way to get the phone?
I was.
It was all so confusing,
but it was a thing where people would
wait in line and then they would look at
each other and I remember when.
I remember when they were waiting in
line for Harry Potter when Harry Potter
was coming out and people would drive by
and they were yelling out,
dumbledore dies at the end.
They're yelling out all these different
spoilers.
All I typed in was waiting in line for
it in Google and the only things that
come up or iphone supreme and iphone
eight or gas.
Yeah,
gas.
We waited in line with the flags.
Red,
green or yellow flag.
What was that?
Uh,
there was like in the mid seventies
there was a gas shortage.
So green meant that you got gas if you
have an odd number,
like if you license play them,
the nod.
Yellow was even and then red was,
was shut down bitch.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
But that they had the flags 73 to 75
maybe something like that.
I don't know the exact dates.
Then they had a weird line.
Studio.
Fifty four had a huge one,
but you got picked studio 54.
The dance club studio.
50 floor was on fire.
You showed up.
You didn't guarantee to get it.
You got picked right the way they do now
in Hollywood,
like they pick hot chicks,
right?
So they pick hot chicks.
What was the thing we were talking about
when they.
They won't let a guy in without a check
something.
Yeah.
Some be to go out and clubs and they'd
never would let guys in without chicks.
So if you walk into a club with three
guys that don't want you,
they want
the chicks in there first.
Yeah.
Well the last thing you want is a
sausage fest.
Look at all those dudes trying to get
in.
Looking to luminous.
That was inside,
but outside that be aligned.
The people or that could be at.
No,
that's outside.
That's outside.
What?
A zoo.
Just to try to get in.
Just to try to get here.
What was the big deal about studio 54?
You could snort coke,
dance.
Get Your Dick sucked and get your shoes
shined all at the same place and be home
by six.
It was a.
You know what I mean?
Everybody with their like that.
Andy Warhol,
but was the girl.
Look at her.
She's got a beer bottle in her mouth,
you know,
champagne.
Champagne.
Yeah.
It's pretty hard.
Fucking black Sabbath four.
Look at Mick Jagger's wife there.
So with the Andy Warhol looking lives
immediately behind them.
Wow.
So it was just like the place to be.
It was the place to be.
You could go crazy.
Strange.
Strange Times,
Huh?
But here's the beauty of it.
They have a station like serious and
it's called studio 54.
You could just put it on Sunday nights.
They do a podcast and what they do is
they interview people that actually used
to go there or work there and I never
tell you something,
Joe.
They had a dentist on about a year ago
and his wife that it was crazy listening
to this interview about what their life
was.
They were professional dentists making
money in New York.
They stayed out till five,
six every night,
but went home,
took the kids to school,
went back home,
took a nap to one,
got up,
went to the dental office work though
five,
went home,
took another nap,
fed the kids and at 9:00
they brought him.
Bring the kids downstairs so they're
moms and they do it all over again.
Five nights a week over and over,
and the lady was saying that until years
later lives in Middle East.
I was a publicist.
She goes,
she didn't know I was a dentist.
They just saw you in there.
Your trust funders,
you know,
that's all the people who could do that
type of shit.
Blow to Lola was a night.
You can put it out.
They even had an interview about when
Bob Hope went to studio 54.
Bob Hope,
Bob Hope Walkman.
The studio that.
No,
what the fuck.
He was going to,
what?
Where he was going to walk into.
He went out to the middle of the floor
and started dancing and these chicks got
together and started tying hope up,
tying them around like an Indian.
He's just standing there like laughing
Bob hope style.
Then it's like,
it's just a fucking joke.
They just left them there and then just
tighten them up and left him there.
Tons of stories like that,
you know,
just.
But then it moved up,
but you got picked to go in there.
How did it move on,
like imagine how weird it must have been
when it finally the door shut and that
was it.
The people were.
It was their whole life.
For years,
people move on,
you know,
clubs get hot,
different clubs.
I went there at one time in 1983,
maybe 84.
It was done.
My friend who's already done it was
done.
It was just a bunch of assholes trying
to be cool.
Wow.
And I followed the hundred dollar bill.
I was out of money with a bag of blow,
no cash,
not a dime in my pocket and I looked
down at four in the morning.
It was $100 bill and that's how I got to
say that's how I got home.
That was it.
That's my studio.
Fifty four story.
It is weird though.
The nightclub scene,
the nightclub scenes are very strange
scene and one club gets hot and then it
dies off and the people that are in that
business like try to figure out what
makes something hot and what doesn't.
You've got to rename places and Redo
them and reopening and grand reopening
and get people to show up.
Like I remember hearing that they were
paying Paris Hilton like shit.
Piles of money to just show up at club
because Kadesh Ian's view those people,
they pay a shit load of money.
You're there to take pictures of your
club gets hot.
Then after about a year you started
taking partners and yeah,
sure.
Because you go what's on the way?
The odds are against you.
So after a year some guy comes,
I love your place and I'll take her and
that's how you get out of it or you do.
A lot of people didn't.
They just liked the place on fire and
stuff and scratch a little Jewish
lightning starts from scratch.
You know?
I knew the guy that owned the gay clubs
in Houston like in the seventies and he
was telling me one time,
he goes,
yeah,
once we got our youth side of him,
you light them on fire collecting
insurance and they'll open up another
club.
That's it.
Jewish,
lightning,
Jesus Christ.
It's a weird scene.
You know what I mean?
People that just look forward to just
going out and just drinking and dancing
and snorting coke every night,
just looking for like experience,
just something different and while that
takes them out of their everyday grind,
just do it over and over and over and
over.
Different.
Like when I was growing up it was club
area was big and the rooftop you paid
like 24 bucks to go in at 11:00
and you drank all night til seven in the
morning.
Twenty four bucks or you could drink it.
Shit.
Booze.
I mean you're not drinking cold Vasa gay
shit when you're doing blow your brother
that shit.
Anyway,
you come up and give you some sunglasses
and that's it.
If you went in after three was,
it was like 20 something after 11 and
then like 17 bucks or you could drink
after three,
so seven in the fucking morning and
people were packed.
That's what New York was about back
then.
It was just people staying there.
I post seven,
six New York has a forum,
last call once,
last call in New York.
I have no idea.
Florida,
I think it's even later than New York,
Florida closes for one hour,
5:00
in the morning.
Let's say you're at the news cafe,
right?
Bullshit,
and we're having a good time at 5:00
they'll come over to you and say,
Hey,
do me a favor by 5:00.
The bars or the clothes so you can order
be at those six.
So we just sold a 25 bids and you wait
til the ball because of six and now
you're fucking ready to drink again.
I got those for one hour.
One hour.
This was back,
you know,
20 years ago,
15 years ago in coconut grove.
And weird rule.
One hour.
Remember that place we used to go to
right down the street from that Improv?
Yeah.
The loose cafe is a great place.
Great place,
great breakfast,
great fucking bar.
The club went downhill hard though.
Yeah.
That club and that place will.
The whole coconut grove area became the
only thing that's still open to the
dueling pianos.
The pizza joint that more the dueling
piano places still ops in that little
mall there with the movie theater.
They always have those right next to
Improv.
It's like they have one in Addison to
right addison.
They have one up next to Jon Lovitz up
and universal.
They do.
Yeah.
They used to.
If there's a fucking pulling up,
their Miami has a 24 hour really
drinking just Miami,
just in Miami entertainment district it
says.
Oh,
well that makes sense.
It's 4:00
AM.
Broward County and key west.
Yeah,
little different everywhere else in
Orlando.
West Palm is where we always worked with
either worked in Miami at the Improv,
which is coconut grove or we did west
palm after Joel opened up that new
place.
The big giant.
That's a great place.
The new place though is like a a
theater.
It's like 600 seats.
It's fucking huge.
I mean,
that's a huge club.
It's a great place that even for love.
That was a great club inside the casino,
which they're redoing over.
Oh yeah,
that shut down.
Oh dear to them next year.
Yeah.
We have no action.
No kidding.
That was a fun little fun little club,
but a good size.
That one in the hard rock is a good size
side.
Yeah.
The last time I was there there was a
couple next to me that was fucking in
the bedroom next to me and like animals.
I mean like fucking animals.
I mean like porno film animals.
Like like I was lying in bed and I heard
that and it was in the afternoon.
I'll try and take a nap and these people
were hammering just bang,
Bang,
Bang.
This
guy's just head.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I fucking Florida oxycodone one of those
pay relief centers.
You take two of those things.
You get hammered with addicted times and
she won't go dead boss route and told
the story.
The other day that I read online,
I'm one of those martial arts websites
about his addiction.
That's a great article.
Ooh,
scary.
Scary Shit.
Or he was talking about trying to get
off of it and how difficult it was,
and you're talking about a guy with like
an iron will,
you know,
in boss route and command and the
average person who just has a hard time
getting out of bed in the morning,
it doesn't have a lot of discipline and
they get hooked.
Like that's it.
That's it.
You're gone.
It's fucking amazing.
That stuff's legal.
Did you watch 60 minutes?
Three weeks ago now?
That was the whole.
That was the motherfuckers.
Motherfuckers wasn't just about the
opioid epidemic and the dea stopped
prosecuting.
The word
came from,
you know,
it's just a nightmare.
They're fucking terrible things.
Listen to those things.
A terrible.
Yeah.
There was a whole article recently about
the company that sells most of the
opioids and the family that's behind
that company and how many billions of
dollars that they've made off the opioid
crisis,
opioid opioid,
or be it how we say opioid.
I always say it wrong once.
I should grips you that synthetic
heroin,
that's what that is.
Essentially.
Yeah,
it's a.
it's a bad grip.
Like I said,
I took a 16th one night in my living
room where they had to lay later and
that was my.
That's my whole resume without guns and
I'm a fucking meal.
I can eat 2000 milligrams of thc and
live a 16th one of those pills.
I popped.
It was just a little piece.
Nothing.
My blood pressure drops so fucking much.
I just laid down with the sleep and I
knew my pill career had come through
that never even let it start.
Really?
Never even let it start.
Can you believe brother?
In two weeks it's going to be 10 years
since I've done that.
Wipe out.
I want you to think about that.
Wow.
I want you to really think about.
I still remember being at Cobb's with
you that January and like go and it's
been two months.
I don't know if I could really do this
shit.
Like I don't know if I control this
feeling and I control it.
So you like when you quit,
what was like the first week like hell,
hell,
first two weeks were hell.
Did you think about going back just
like,
I can't do this,
or did you know that you had had to make
a change?
I had to make a change.
I knew that my spine was starting to
hurt.
I knew the spineless started hurting.
I was trying to get job just by four in
the morning.
You know,
after you do coke right at the tip over
here,
people have done coke at like
Parkinson's gives a fuck that.
No,
no,
no.
Once.
I think that's related while a lot.
A lot of old timers that did a lot of
coke in the seventies and then they
wound up like some serious neuromuscular
Muskegon,
absolute.
That shit's shocks.
Just central nervous system.
There was times I did cocaine that was
electric.
It was like when you put that thing in
your hand or you get electrocuted,
you could feel the electric and your
body and next day like that in your
brain,
like you can actually see the neural
transmitters a fucking on fire.
You could feel that.
You know,
I could tell when I would go on stage
after doing two or three nights of blow
that week,
I had no control.
I really had no control over my
material.
I had no control over my delivery.
That's what I wanted to tell you.
Like you're just the way you off.
Yeah.
Your mind can't grip it.
You can't sell the joke.
The facial doesn't connect with the hand
movement or the breathing.
So like,
I knew that that was always going to be
a danger in the future.
Now,
you know,
I take all that,
uh,
for like a year I drank those,
what's your buddy's name that makes the
neurosurgeon milkshakes?
The football player that fucking beat
the guy up and asking.
I took all his stuff for like a year
just to.
Yeah,
the orange drink and snack for neuro
one.
That stuff it got.
Yeah,
it felt good.
It felt a lot better.
Give your brain some nutrient control.
Yeah.
But 10 years,
I mean that,
that uh,
I had to do a benefit and hoboken and I
had gotten.
I like that whole summer I tried to get
off coke.
I was doing the heroin that was trying
to get off the coke and shit and then
that September I read the heroin,
so I was doing it like maybe once a week
and the whole thing went down in
Maryland.
I knew I had to stop and then I had this
thing in hoboken.
I went whole thing went down,
Maryland Martinez.
She was dying.
I went,
I went back east that week and she was
dying.
I don't know what happened.
It was like,
you know what?
I was trying to get coke on Friday
night.
I couldn't get it and I just took it for
what it was.
I was trying to get coconut Saturday.
I couldn't get it,
so fuck it.
I took the plane back Sunday.
I couldn't get it here.
Something happened.
I couldn't get it.
And then that Monday I had a meeting to
do a movie and at the end of the meeting
the guy said,
listen man,
we know about your drug problem.
So before you say yes,
we want you to think about this because
you can't miss a day on this movie.
You cannot be late if you're late to the
whole movie.
Can't shoot because it was a cast.
We all shot in one room was in a
meeting,
so I thought about it,
I'll do it and that was the roughest
fucking month because I was just going
home and before 8:00
would start,
I would just go to bed.
At 8:00
was my cocaine time.
That's what my body would start to ache.
That's when I couldn't even.
You could be telling me the most
important thing in your life and I'd be
watching you,
but I couldn't hear.
All my mind was focused on was getting
that blow at 8:00
and then I would figure out how to get
to 60 bucks.
You know,
I'm going to go to the ATM machine.
I would shoot over the rock and roll
routes.
There's an ATM machine in front of rock
and roll.
Ralph's right there.
Yeah.
And I would take 60 bucks out there.
I would rather you red light to get to
the ATM machine,
but it doesn't give a fuck.
We to give a fuck.
And then from there we just make the u
turn,
go to my dealer's house,
go home and leave the coke there and now
is ready for the night.
I was in peace just knowing that the
coke was at the house,
I didn't have to do it.
You know,
I
don't,
I've never been physically addicted to
something in a way where I had a hard
time kicking it.
But I've had some psychological
addictions for sure.
And I think that one of the things that
I've gotten out of this month of no
sober October thing that Tom Burton,
Ari and I are doing is that a lot of it
is psychological.
A lot of it is psychological.
It's just knowing that we can't smoke
pot or can't drink all month.
You start thinking about,
oh,
we're at the homestretch November first
round the corner.
Like I don't really feel like I need to
get high.
It's not like our needed a drink
tomorrow,
but it's knowing that I can't do it for
the month where it hangs over your head.
So that's what's even more impressive
that you could kick it because it's not
just the fact that you have like a
physical problem,
but you also have the psychological
problem,
like the psychological part of it is
like it's a pattern that you're
comfortable with.
You got used to that pattern of 8:00,
you looking for the coke,
you go and do it and then you're off.
It's like you're off.
Even though you're in chaos,
your life's in disarray and you're in
the grips of addiction.
You're comfortable with that feeling.
You've been there before and you're for
whatever reason,
when people get used to fucking up and
they go,
why do I keep fucking up?
One of the reasons you keep fucking up
because you're used to fuck us it.
And it's not an uncomfortable feeling in
the sense that it's,
it's you know,
it,
it might suck,
but you know,
it's the devil,
you know,
that was nice.
I didn't want to do it.
I still did it.
Can this family.
I didn't want to do it.
Like I didn't need to do it.
Like I didn't feel.
I just want to do it,
but it was just something to do,
like it was just something to do.
Wow.
It was just something to do,
but you know what I tell people all the
time is you want to have to quit.
It just doesn't happen.
Like I quit at 44.
I'm no fucking genius,
but it took me two years.
Like it was a two year struggle,
like a personal little struggle.
Like when did you know that it was with
you that you were free
because you didn't go to Aa?
Na narcotics anonymous.
I went to one meeting in a meeting and I
wanted Hollywood,
which everything is good until you go to
it and Hollywood because Hollywood,
you act that you,
you add the dramatic and the actor image
to it.
You know,
if you go to an AA meeting in jersey,
they're in this smoking camel,
reds fucking talking from the heart.
You're going to have a meeting and
Hollywood.
You got people with eight tattoos on
their own.
How can each other,
you know it's a fucking jam burry.
They're just happy to be in a new clan
that they're in and then what happens is
after about two months in this area,
for some reason I have noticed because I
have a lot of friends in a date,
somebody approaches you and says hi,
you know what's going on?
And you're like,
I'm struggling with like,
why have you seen Dr Bob?
Dr Bob Gross.
I'm just making this.
I talked to Bob.
Oh my God,
to tell them about Dr.
Bob told Joe about Dr Bob.
Dr Bob has changed your whole life.
So basically you'll see Dr Bob.
He goes,
your bullshit referendum.
Whatever,
a prescription,
what you have.
Oh,
you're bipolar,
you're this.
Now they start shooting adderall,
adderall,
all the other shit.
So you're really sober.
A,
you're really not so,
but you see now after I got clean,
I discovered I had a problem.
I discovered I was bipolar or Johnny
bots or this or that or this or that.
Medication they give you,
you know,
on top of the opiod epidemic.
How bad a fucking adderall.
Adderall is so fucked up.
We have someone every month
that's on when they're doing the
podcast,
it's obvious.
Yes,
they can't shut the fuck up.
They talking to very fast paced.
They're really excited to you.
Just a little bit too much energy.
There's something about them that you
just know and you just like.
You could tell like you're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
slow down.
Sometimes I'll offer him a drink.
I mean I've had people on the podcast
where I tried to figure out what the
fuck was going on and then later on in
the podcast they told me they did
adderall and I was like,
okay,
now I get it.
Oh wait,
no,
world is tensioned.
It's crazy chick.
We knew that you should take to
adderalls and fucking chicken west palm
or something.
Used to drink.
Oh,
to.
To everybody does.
Do you.
Do you know how many people do it
though?
I'm getting stunned.
All my families that I know,
like with my kids are friends with
their,
their kids and I get to know these
people.
Fucking these all these like successful
suburban people are doing adderall the
time.
That's how they get through work.
That's how they become successful.
They're always hustling.
They're always getting things done,
and these motherfuckers,
they always want the newest shit.
They want the newest watch.
Oh,
is that the newest Hugh Bowl?
Is that the newest?
This is that the newest dad.
Oh,
he's got the Mercedes amg.
Oh look,
he's got this and she's there.
She bought a house in the oaks.
Oh look at this and she's got that and
we'll get that purse.
Yeah.
Where'd you get that?
Heard that.
Such a Hermes.
Oh,
you can't get those.
All they're doing is like chasing after
these things so they can go places and
other people will look at this new thing
that they have.
It's very strange.
It's like there's one thing like if you
know someone who collects a certain
thing,
like there were really into fucking
whatever it is,
old Samurai swords or something like
that though.
They love the history of it.
That's not what these people are doing.
They're buying things so that they could
bring places and other people would go,
Woo.
So they get a feeling like a feeling of
a,
I guess a successful feeling.
You know,
they get a feeling from other people
recognizing that they have the latest
thing.
Like,
Oh,
where'd you get that jacket?
look at that purse.
Oh,
look at that.
We could that chain.
How many carats is that ring?
Let me see your ring.
Oh girlfriend,
let me see your ring.
Amazing.
It's so cute.
Those shoes are so cute.
Oh my God.
So cute.
And they're just like weird fucking just
pilled up people Weirdo,
speeded up people that are like chasing
after the next object.
It's a ferry.
It's a very strange.
And they don't talk about shit.
I get together with these people,
you know,
because we'll have dinners together or
our families would get together,
the kids would play and we'll go to a
party together and you know,
a good 20 percent of these people do not
talk about shit.
All they talk about is objects.
It's talking about this object and that
object and how much this is worth and
how much real estate's going for here.
And that's the whole focus of
conversation.
It's like an anti human conversation
because they're not talking about
anything human.
They're not talking about,
you know,
the community,
what they love about life and their
experiences as a parent and none of that
man,
a lot of them don't even pay attention
to their kids.
They,
they,
they go and drink and leave the kids
outside and the kids are just fucking
hitting other kids with sticks and shit
and go and study and then when they come
out,
oh my kid's a good kid,
he doesn't do that.
Then they go back inside and drink more
and it's like crazy.
It's really interesting to see.
It's like the things that fuel success
in a lot of people are a lot of these
folks.
It's like this,
this need for material possessions and
then pills and this is,
this is what's going on.
You didn't come you with a different
company.
The best home conditions available to
us,
you know,
fucking brady bunch in your house.
I'm not insulting.
You know,
you're just saying that you had to
deliver papers,
that your mother had a work and Lou with
the whole fucking thing.
You have a sit there sometimes at one of
these fucking parties with these people
who have everything,
everything we didn't have and you'll
like.
My parents were 20 times better than
these fucking people.
As a parent,
like I'm sitting there every day now
that I'm a parent,
I go to pools,
I go to gymnastics tonight,
I got a fucking recital.
I mean I have to do this.
Who the fuck apart of my I am,
but I see these people that do this shit
and I'm like,
my mother was a fucking booky.
My mother on the ball and she was a
drunk and she was way better parents and
these fucking cops because she was
there.
Interest is what it is.
I think what we're talking about with
this pill thing,
there's a lot of people that are on
antidepressants.
There's a lot of people that are on
adderall does.
A lot of people are on Xanax.
There's a lot of people that are a lot
of weird disassociated lives and these
disassociative pills,
you see it in how they interact with
their children.
They just,
they just zone out.
They're not there.
Even if you're like stressed out about
your kid and you're interacting with
your kid,
at least the kid knows you're
communicating with them and then the
kids probably not happy that you're
stressed out,
but at least you're there when you're
zoned out on pills and staring at the
fucking clouds.
It's just,
it's just not.
It's not a good way for human beings to
interact with each other while you're
hopped up on some weird shit and I
think,
I mean,
I don't know what the actual numbers
are,
but are in the communities that I
associate with.
I would say a good solid half of these
fucking people are pilled up a good
solid half.
They're either pilled up on Xanax.
What's really hilarious as I've talked
to some of these people and they're
like,
I don't know how you get smoked pot
every day.
I'm like,
bitch,
you take a xanax every morning.
Every morning you take a xanax.
I know a lady who takes xanax every time
she gets in her car,
she was like,
just too much traffic.
Book Pop,
Xanax for traffic.
They pop a Xanax to go to sleep.
They pop a xanax because they have to
fly.
Oh,
I have to fly.
I need a Xanax.
I've even got A.
Yeah.
For those.
For our flights,
I just can't sit there no more.
Well,
those intervals make you think about the
universe.
I mean people say Ooh,
excuse and I'm not trying to be a
different thing.
It's a different thing though.
When I have mercy in the morning,
I don't fucking get high,
don't get high.
Like I have her in the mornings before
school and I drive.
I try to because I got to walk into
school,
want to read like it.
They already wanted me one time.
They wanted you to smell like pick her
up and one of the teachers came in and
she goes a little last Friday.
You were kicking pungent last Friday so
I can't embarrass my daughter.
So I tried to read that was it.
Once they said it,
that's funny.
Then the afternoons I'd take my chances.
I get high,
go to the gym.
This class was swimming or the ballet or
whatever the fuck we you have to do.
And then after that,
you know,
I'm out with my friends or doing the
podcasts or doing comedy.
So,
but adderall and I don't have beer in my
house.
You don't really drink,
you've never been.
I don't want to.
I don't want alcohol in my house now
that have a child.
I don't want alcohol in my house.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
if there's one thing that I could kick
that,
uh,
you know,
like sober October Shit,
like if I could,
uh,
if I had to choose like for the rest of
my life,
no boobs are no pot.
I would say no booze in a heartbeat.
Yeah.
But I like the cold Heineken attempt,
cold,
fucking delicious.
But I get something out of pot.
I get like sensitivity.
I get community,
I get compassion,
I get introspective thinking,
I start,
I examined myself more.
I become more humble.
I get something out of it.
I get real benefits out of pot.
Like a lot of the benefits of benefits
that some people would call paranoia or
you know,
the,
the people,
uh,
they freak out because,
you know,
they think the walls are closing in.
I love that.
That's.
Yeah,
that's good for you.
I live in that world.
I fucking love it.
I love somebody telling me I'm a loser.
Gather together.
Have been done.
Dick Today.
Get out of fucking you.
Watch TV A.
I've taken it the proud of.
I'm very proud of Bert Kreischer for
cooking the booze this month and let's
hope it stays off of it.
Well,
or at least,
what do you think of regulates it?
You put these guys in Rehab this month.
Pretty much think of Rehab is rehab is
just to let you know where you stand.
Sixty days of you that are doing a
certain something makes you know where
you stand and sometimes you'll go,
you know what,
Joe Rogan,
I'm not going to smoke pot,
but I'm going to have my drink twice a
week.
That's too.
You know,
bird has a prom flying,
you know,
he likes to fucking get twisted.
You know Birch,
what you call a social drink,
some fucking Florida.
Yeah.
Know they wake up,
they have the little fucking Cock Pale,
whatever.
The ticket nap,
they go to the beach.
You would.
I don't know,
that life.
I've never lived that life of drinking
all day and then taking them that Brits
are real soldier,
you know,
bridge not fucking around Bernstein on
amateur show birds,
the real deal.
I saw him running a couple of tasks on.
I'm running through my car and when he
was running at me,
this shit with this little thing.
I just took the car and just started
going at him and he's like,
Eh,
last.
They looked at me.
He's like,
ah,
because he's in my neighborhood.
So I saw,
I watched them a lot.
I went over there.
I tried to get them high.
He wouldn't fall.
Bring,
uh,
he was going to bring a drug tests the
other day when we were,
I was on number 13,
I think,
and day we're on number 14.
And Red was gonna stop at Cvs and pick
up those marijuana tests.
But he just didn't have the time.
I'm very proud of birth and all of this
is going to let you do look at even you
with the reef of them.
It's going to let you know that you
didn't have too much.
Like when I went to prison,
the hardest thing about prison wasn't
going to prison.
You know it was,
how am I going to live without my
marijuana?
Really?
I'm I going to fuck you sleep.
I wasn't worried about nothing else in
prison except marijuana.
I didn't get any in prison.
No,
you could $50 bucks for two joints.
I will brown weed.
I wasn't doing that,
but after the first week you learned
about yourself.
You learned that you could go with that,
which is one of the strongest things
that could happen to somebody.
It's like when you're.
When you're in love with that girl and
you're destroying your life,
your job,
your drink,
and you act like an asshole and then she
goes away to Hawaii for two weeks.
After 10 days you're like,
fuck that bitch.
When you did people get divorced when
they lot.
When their wives leave for 10 days.
Yeah.
The wife goes back to see the mother.
You're sitting there going,
what am I doing?
What am I doing?
I'm much happier in this house.
I could put her in the back somewhere
and not see.
Know that's what happens when you
realize you could do without.
That's one of the biggest things in your
world that could happen to date.
You have no idea.
Well,
you don't think you could do without in
the beginning because you think maybe
you could possibly get her back.
If you can get it back,
everything's going to go.
You got this bad feeling because she's
thinking about leaving.
You're like,
oh no,
she's going to leave Melbourne.
Maybe I can talk her back in.
Maybe I could buy or something.
Maybe I can do something.
Maybe we changed my weights and I'll
bring her back and I'll bring her back
and everything's gonna be fine,
but everything is fine and if she leaves
you just meet somebody else.
Just come on,
relax a second,
and I gave up sodas.
I never thought I could give her a coke
and fucking crazy like those.
Do you like those things?
What?
Oh Jamie enough.
So what's the seaview Zevia sodas with
that flavor with Stevia.
People think I'm doing a fucking
commercial for these things.
They don't.
They haven't paid me a nickel.
I'm not taking it in their money to
their soda,
but their flavor with Stevia and you
don't get no sugar at all.
They have like,
um,
raspberry.
They have um,
root beers.
They have like one that's like a seven
up.
They have one that's like a grapefruit
soda.
They have a bunch of different ones.
Man.
They're fucking great.
I love them.
I'm so hooked on water.
The water's great too.
I don't give a fuck anymore out of these
stupid things.
So they do have a cola one,
right?
Give them that cream soda.
That one's the shit.
That right there.
Bam.
Diet Cola,
diet coke sucks.
About a month ago I was on a plane and I
was a little loopy.
I just said,
let me try it.
Coke,
coke.
I couldn't even finish the little
fucking eight ounce glass.
We only.
Sweet.
Yeah,
day accidentally.
I was late night drive through starving,
coming off from the store and I got a
burger and I asked for a diet coke and
they gave me a regular coke and I went,
oh,
this is so good.
Who was so delicious?
The once a month I'm going to give
myself a coke or actual cocacola once a
month.
Once you get the Mexican ones with the
rule.
Yeah,
the Medical Silica Taco joint.
Go to cactus and where you guys usually
go right there.
They fucking good.
But once you realize like you know we
gotta I grew up in Jersey.
I got the sandwich,
I got a bag of chips.
Right.
It's not the sandwich that killed.
It's a bag of chips.
If I haven't Turkey with Swiss and
Avocado,
I'm not going to fucking die.
Right.
It's the fucking point two ounce bag of
chips.
All those things.
Once you give them up,
like I had to give him up a
weightwatchers.
They were tough potatoes with breakfast.
That was tough.
Those.
Yup.
For me,
it's when switching over to like in and
out and getting a double double with the
lettuce,
with lettuce,
rapping on the top of it or whatever
that's called it protein style to stuff.
That's the way to go because you still
enjoy the shit out of it.
Tastes amazing,
but you're not getting all that bread.
It's still fantastic and it's really not
bad for you.
I mean it's just ground beef,
cheese,
lettuce.
It's not.
I mean there's nothing terrible for you
there.
I just think that,
you know,
when you spend too much time eating
shitty food,
your body is going to just feel
terrible,
but if you could just limit that shitty
food to occasionally,
then you'll appreciate.
Enjoy just for have meatball sub know
every,
every now and then,
you know,
Loretta's ever go to Cabaretta fucking
place.
So good.
I get a sausage and pepper sub there
every now and then.
Ooh,
was real Italian bread.
I mean,
it's a fucking thick outer crust,
Italian bread.
We can clamp it down and it's hard on
the outside,
but soft on the inside.
You bite into that and you feel that
real juicy Italian sausage and that
Marinara sauce.
Two weeks,
two weeks,
two weeks ago,
I go home with two week.
Oh,
you're going home in two weeks.
I save everything for when I go home.
I don't fuck around no more.
I don't eat Chinese food out of him no
more.
Don't do you don't fuck around though.
What about pizza?
Do you fuck around?
Why?
I had to stop.
I gotTa Stop Sam.
I got a place by my house.
I got to tell you something.
If I walk in there with you,
you'll drive them really good.
Don't take the pie the go.
No,
you don't get enough credit.
Just slice.
You got to get the slices to the
rotating.
You bring that pie hole.
It's like a fucking falafel,
like you've got to bring it home and put
it in Europe and all over again.
That's the secret.
You have to put a your and all over.
You know and no one does right here.
White Pizza?
No,
because no was Catholic.
There was a fucking.
There's a pizza place in white plains,
New York,
down the street from executive
billiards,
I think it was Nicky's Nicky's pizzeria,
and they had this fucking white cheese
sliced this white pizza slice width and
it had like you could see the olive oil
and butter and the pizza and the garlic
and you would bite into it.
You'd be like,
holy Christ,
and the Cross to the pizza underneath is
just like the just the right amount of
cooked where there was like a little bit
of a slight burn to the crossed and
you're biting into it and you just feel
in the cheese,
in the dough and all the sauces and the
whole awesome fucking during lent.
When you grow up back then you go to
your friend's house on Friday,
they got like muscles and red sauce and
Nikki's.
That's the place and white fucking
pizza.
We'd walk to that place right from
executive billions right down the
street.
Fucking phenomenal place.
So are good street,
fight their wants and that's what it
means.
The other thing that bothers me the
most,
you know the slices,
two slices.
Yeah,
because a move,
a slice is a thing of the move.
Okay.
What's a slice of a move?
A slice of a move as you mean you're on
the fucking move.
When I come in to see Joe's pizza and I
go,
let me get to cheese to go and you give
them to me the thing and I fold them up.
I eat one there and take one with and
went to go get a slice in Hollywood.
Somewhat.
What happens?
They take it,
they write a receipt,
they hang it up and some other guy
comes,
takes the slice out,
puts it in.
You have to wait for 10 minutes.
Then they come with a number and they
give me the fucking slice.
Listen,
do it all.
One shot.
Use your dirty hands and ain't going to
kill me.
They ain't going to kill.
We have them give a fuck if you scratch.
Yes,
grow the fuck the heat from the oven.
They'll kill the job.
She know what I'm saying.
Just troll the slicing.
Everything's a process.
A slice.
That's the whole corporate.
Yeah,
it's a move.
It's like that shit.
I know what you mean.
Everything has become corporate and
these places that you're never going to
get that old small restaurant feel from
place like this that you'll get from a
place like Nikki's pizzeria.
You know you don't and that the flavors
are different.
We've talked about this before.
I don't know what it is,
and I've heard people say it's the
water,
but whatever it is,
the place down the block from Gotham.
That's what I can do.
Golf.
I'll show you this slide right here.
I even took a picture of that guy that
got shot in there that'll make you
asshole fallout in this.
I just took a bite of it.
I will need a host from boat.
That's a heart attack at night.
That's a delicious meal whether
Stromboli,
but that's a heart attack.
That's,
you know.
Well,
it's got a good trumball yeah.
Vegas.
Vegas is a place of Vegas that you got
to Stromboli and they put.
They have couches in the back.
Well,
they must have leftover.
If we can take a nap,
take a nap.
I have leftover guineas from when the
mob ran vegas.
Right.
You could use to go to a place that,
uh,
emily used to take you to the Italian
pool place that you said,
this place.
That place went under,
unfortunately.
Did.
Yeah,
it did.
That place was fantastic.
That was some of the best Italian food
in Vegas.
And you would get it at a pool hall.
It was so weird.
Okay.
Beautiful.
That slices put the fucking
sauces from Bali.
My Nice Guy.
That's like a florist with beautiful
flowers.
This is dose or models.
Cuban restaurant.
They'd been serving Cuban steak
sandwiches is 1960.
That's all they do.
The steak sandwiches a place west,
New York,
New Jersey.
That's the place we took pictures of
people.
So that's beauty.
That's Mona Lisa.
My world.
Look at the Strombolis.
Look at his phone is filled with
pictures.
Lots of tales.
The day.
The one from Jersey with the cream of
them place here.
You can have all those Italian fucking
cookie.
Look at that.
Fucking look at that.
Fucking.
What does that mean?
What do you call those?
Yeah.
Fucking cannoli.
Oh my God.
Oh.
Can take pictures of my kids.
Take pictures of food.
Fuck the kid.
Give me pictures of food.
Food.
I just take pictures.
I could show people here.
We're missing
like this is what this doing this yoga
thing where I did nine,
10 yoga classes in a row,
whatever it was.
I think it was 10 you.
I'm hungry all the time because I'm
doing 90 minutes of yoga every day,
every single day.
Not a day off for nine days or whatever
it was.
Let's say it was nine,
but even if it was nine,
I took a day off before that I did two
days in a row,
so it's like over the last couple of
days or last couple of weeks it was 11
classes in,
mostly in a row and just always hungry.
Just constantly hungry like your body is
just craving it and so I've been eating
all sorts of shit that I never allow
myself to eat like late night,
like grabbing a burger on the.
Like I had a Wendy's burger last night.
Coming home from the store.
Not good for you,
but felt good.
Well,
you burned right through that.
I do work out a lot through.
It's still not the smartest thing to do,
just not.
I feel so much better when I don't do
that.
When I just limit myself to that.
Like once a week I feel so much better,
but I just,
I don't,
I don't necessarily think it's good to
do anything nine days in a row.
I just feel like your body's just like,
I've got a weird hamstring pull that's
going on right now and he just.
Everything feels like a little worn out.
You didn't run this month?
I didn't run but one one day.
The first week of the month I lifted
weights a couple times here and there,
but almost the entire month has been
yoga
so far with the aid.
Jujitsu's eight,
you know when I go on the road and
pickle and the weights and I do this
little fucking kettlebell crawl,
little bag,
my backyard just to get that hip thing
going.
So I laid this fertile,
glossy stuff.
No,
I decided like somebody told me to crawl
and I started crying like,
you're in the army,
like in get back yard.
I started crawling.
I fucking love around your yard.
Yeah,
just crawl around for yourself
when your hips.
This shit.
Do all this shit on your elbows.
I like it.
So I've been doing that,
but when the gym's install,
the gym's going to be installed here in
two weeks.
You got to come by and we'll do a
workout.
Want you to teach me the Doris and all
that stuff?
Half guard and all that stuff.
Okay,
great.
Sure.
That's great that you got this place.
This is a fucking big place.
Crazy place,
right?
But it's this place.
We're going to do all kinds of stuff
here.
We're gonna.
Have it set up where people could follow
along workouts.
I'm going to get someone to like guide
us through a workout and I'll say,
hey,
everybody,
grab a 35 pound Kettlebell.
We're going to go through this.
Like that Keith Weber guy that I've had
on before,
Keith Weber.
I'll get him to come up here and teach
that extreme Kettlebell,
extreme cardio workouts.
Fucking phenomenal workout that you
could do with 1:35
pound Kettlebell and you'll pick up a 35
pound Kettlebell.
You want to fucking workout,
I'm going to get with this little that
does it.
Five minutes and you'll be dying.
Guaranteed.
One hundred percent.
Even if you're in good shape,
it's hard if you're not used to.
That workout is fucking hard and by the
time the things over my legs are on
fire.
Thirty five pounds,
35 pounds.
What kind of Shit are you doing?
Like,
oh,
clean presses over and over again.
Hot potatoes,
back and forth,
renegade rows.
You're doing like one pushup with one
hand on the Kettlebell switch to the
other side.
Push up with the other one doing.
I'm passing in between your legs and you
go one after the other,
one after the other windmills over and
over.
Cleaned press snatches,
and you're doing these in succession.
Over and over again.
Switch to this side.
Switch to the other side,
10 on this side,
10 on that side.
You know,
and it's,
we're talking about like a 45 minute
workout.
We have them.
You can,
you could buy them all over the place,
but we have him on it.
He's got three of them out,
three different workouts.
They're fucking crazy dvds.
I mean this,
this guy is,
he's a trainer up in Canada.
It's just in tremendous shape,
but the videos are so good because it's
one of the few videos where a lot of
these kettlebell workout videos like
people were teaching you proper form,
which is all important.
You know,
it's real important to like learn proper
form,
learn where to peep to keep the weight
balanced,
keep your weight in your heels and your
feet flat on the ground.
All the different things that they want
you to stress about various individual
movements.
But Keith Weber's like,
you better know all that shit because
we're just going to take you through a
radical workout like ready?
Here we go.
Boom.
And he does.
He's doing it all with you.
He's doing it on the beach.
It's awesome and crazy shit.
The other guy's good too,
from a burden.
He's good too.
He's got a nice little workout in the
mornings that.
Oh yeah,
that's kettle Jitsu guys.
That guy up at 5:30
AM,
5:30
AM.
I watched it online.
Five 30 am,
5:30
AM.
He's got like fucking stack of people in
there.
They go right to Jujitsu.
It's how great will it be?
The show up?
I gotta get up at three Am.
Yeah,
be ready at 5:30
for that type of shit.
Have coffee.
I got to have coffee,
smoke pot.
I have a protein shake right a little
bit.
Just so not the thing.
I get fired up.
I can't.
I'll have a heart attack.
I just can't get up and go over there.
The good thing about doing a workout
like that before Jujitsu is that you'll
approach Jujitsu like light.
Is this him kettle Jitsu?
Yeah.
He's got a,
a good program like he's doing hip
escapes is call it snake moves while
he's holding onto a Kettlebell at the
same time.
That's phenomenal for your core.
He's a rocking chair.
Get ups.
You know what I really like,
man.
I do.
Um,
these sit ups with kettlebells or I put
a 2:55
pound kettle bells or 50 pound kettle
bells a over my feet.
I put my feet through the handles and
then I put two in my hands and I lay
back on my back and I press them up and
then I sit up with impressed up and I do
my sit ups that way and it just makes
your core,
your,
your ab muscles just so God damn strong.
Twenty five you give me.
I don't tie my feet and what I do is I
go back and then we'll go this way.
I do like a fucking burpee.
Oh,
okay.
No,
that's great.
I grew up on my back,
but I do that and then stand back up all
the way up.
No,
no,
I just bull Bam.
Go back in the band,
but at least it's like getting onto the
table.
That's what getting into a table.
I wanted to the strength and all that
shit and that helped me strengthen my
back doing that stuff.
Those are great workouts because they're
not.
It's not like a glamorous thing where
pumps you up,
gives you a big.
It makes it look Jack,
but it's just great for your
circulation.
Then I told her the bag in the.
Oh yeah,
showed a warm up.
I opened up with the bag very lightly.
Pry minutes,
close distance than spread out punches.
Just get everything moving,
pushup stretched.
Once you do 20 minutes at Dan,
I started doing my stretches to really
get the muscles are warm.
Then I go back,
now I start throwing kicks that kills
Uncle Joey.
Once I start throwing the Kix,
Kix kix sixth and like crawl.
But I do make cleans.
I do all the stuff with a 15 pounds and
now it's still using the kettle bells
swings that we're in the middle of my
back.
I used to fifteens I turned my arms,
go up,
boom.
Catch him.
Oh,
so you're raising the club's got them
from onnit man,
they,
they're fucking great.
Do you,
uh,
do you ever do Turkish getups?
I do up to a degree too.
So I take the 10,
whatever it is,
boom,
boom.
And then I do like a table instead of
getting.
Okay,
well that's good.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
no,
no I do it that.
I like all that stuff.
Any of that stuff.
Like when you're lying down on your back
and you're pressing something up and
even just getting up to your knee,
it's all just about strengthening your
core,
you know?
Do you do anything for your legs?
Do you do like bodyweight squats for
your legs?
Squats,
the goblets.
You don't have to do it with your,
with the way to do it.
I do.
I start with nothing.
And then I worked myself up to a 35
goblet.
Uh,
and then I do,
you know what man?
My knees are kind of.
Yeah.
You've always had some knee issues,
right?
The left one,
the right one now is a little funky.
So I,
I stopped with the swings.
I love cleans with kettlebells.
That's my shit.
So I liked the combination.
Clean my hand down squat.
Oh,
those are great.
That's what I do.
Another clean squat and I do five on
each side.
Nobody run you through a program or do
you just come up with this on your own?
Wherever I've worked with,
I was going to take the door off and
then got and then just decided to do
whatever you want.
Alberto is there,
my wife got me a bag for Christmas.
I got two kettlebells from you.
Do you want to join us if we do some
sort of a challenge,
some next level challenge,
some next thing you want to join in,
which you do like.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just thinking.
I just.
This is one of the things that I've
realized from this,
doing the 15 yoga classes,
I would fucking never do nine yoga
classes in a row like that.
I would never do nine days in a row.
And last I said I was going to do it,
but once you say you're going to do
something and you do it,
it's not that hard.
You just,
you just wind up doing it,
you know,
like you have to do it.
Like my alarm goes off at seven,
I'm out the door,
I get to the class,
I do the fucking 90 minute class and
then I'm done and then I'd go do my shit
and then I know the next day when I'm
getting.
It doesn't matter if I get home from the
store at 1:00
in the morning,
my alarms going off at seven,
I'm getting up,
I'm having a cup of coffee.
I go there fast and I just have coffee.
You work out early?
Yeah,
I didn't like getting up and work.
I'm good at,
but whoever the twelfth.
I have 11:00
podcasts a lot of times.
Like today's 11:00
podcast,
so I'm up.
You know,
I already got a 90 minute workout in.
I come here,
you know,
stop at like a whole foods or something
like that.
Get a coconut milk,
eat something good to get the coconut
milk mental that mix it with the asa
even though Jesus Christ,
it's delicious.
Couple ice cubes.
Yeah.
I never liked the ISI even though,
but they ran out.
They started sending somebody that.
I'm like,
beggars can't be choosy.
Good.
Google we google.
It's very good.
You know.
Then the good thing about that hemp
force protein is it's very little sugar
commscope.
Couple grams of sugar per coconut milk.
No,
I like it.
I liked that one.
I don't mind doing the challenge.
Here's the problem,
Joe Rogan.
Here's the problem.
What happens that a lot of people don't
realize?
I go to Jujitsu,
right?
Let's say I go to Alberto's.
Alberto's has some fucking killers in
there,
so I'll do the break.
The guard,
pass the guard,
right?
A couple of those and then we start
rolling.
Will a guy like me and an older guy
starts rolling that for the second five
minute roll.
He's opened up.
He's,
Oh,
I'm open.
Like I called dolce,
which my problem,
how come I'm not breathing?
He goes,
you know what?
I got to work them out in the back for
45 minutes before.
Because they can't breathe either.
It's just,
just go with it.
So if I do more than those two roles is.
So law diminishing returns,
I really can't walk the next day.
It's,
it's hard,
but you got to build up to it.
You've got to build up to it.
So that's what I'm.
That's why I liked the southern guy in a
way.
Because you work one day,
you drill,
you know what day you work.
I could do a wait shit,
like I like wait shit.
I was thinking of joining your buddy's
gym for a really good workout.
Tyree norris.
Terry.
Uh,
if that's the one in studio city or
Barry North.
Terry claim on.
There's a Terry Clay bond.
Is the guy who used to train with WHO's
in Hollywood?
A former boxer.
Yeah,
he's in.
He's in.
He's in Burbank.
His,
he really fuck it.
He has a group on for like 30 visits for
teaching people how to box.
Terry Norris was a mother fucker little
corner store.
It's up to quarter from a,
it's up to quarter from a famous
bodybuilding gym,
but it's right there up the corner from
this fucking great restaurant at that
breakfast restaurant and he's right
there.
How is he like talking and everything?
His yard because they had a thing on him
on television.
He's having some issues.
I pick his wife.
Is there somebody else there?
But he's had cause.
Yeah.
She said that.
It's interesting because like he said
all these issues,
but then once he starts hitting the bag
and he's brand new,
he comes back and he looks like Terry
Norris of old.
It's just talk in and struggling,
you know,
he just,
I remember seeing him once,
um,
I was at a boxing match.
I was actually with dom irrera and Terry
nars too.
They're talking to people and this is
before he had had retired,
like officially.
And uh,
he was talking to somebody and you could
hear the slurring and I was like,
whoa.
Like I had no idea,
no idea.
It was this bad,
you know,
all those guys,
those guys that are in wars,
like,
you'll,
you will run into them one day and you
will see it all and see the war in their
voice.
You'll see it in the slurring and the,
the,
the weird ticks and the movements.
And you're like,
oh,
you're looking at a,
a frazzled person there.
You know,
they're shattered to Jamie show you the
hit from last night.
The one you watch the football last
night.
Oh No,
what happened?
Somebody gets smashed or uh,
but you know what's crazy?
This was football thing years ago now
that fucking done like that.
I hit this hard anymore though.
You can't.
Well,
how'd this guy get hit so hard?
Yeah.
So the,
the main issue on it,
as I could say,
a quarterback play,
they do the thing where they are,
I guess they're called Kit.
It's giving up their body.
They slide with their legs first.
They're not supposed to get hit,
like in almost anywhere.
Maybe supposed to tap them just to like
let another down.
Um,
so this guy gives up his legs.
Let me see if I can find the video to
try and that while I'm talking.
But uh,
he gets hit really,
really hard.
And then when you see it in slow Mo,
it kind of makes it a little worse
because the dude lead with design arm to
them right in the home.
Oh,
it goes like this job you seeing,
you're like,
damn,
I'm surprised that.
And throw them out.
Like I didn't watch the game when I got
up this morning.
It was all over the place at late.
It laid it.
I wonder if one day they're going to be
able to figure this.
Is it right here?
Yeah.
Here we go.
Running Tome.
Oh Jesus.
Why is that Guy Mad?
Because it's a late hit.
They got furious at them.
Say it again.
They'll say they're going to show it
from other angles and you'll see
technic quarterbacks a big deal.
That's the guy that hit him.
40 seven.
Kiki Alonzo.
I thinks his name.
Kiko.
That's the guy who got hit.
Joe Flacco for the Ravens.
Here we go.
He's running.
This is the angle for.
Well,
he was already coming like,
how's he going to stop it?
Stop.
That's the part about the slide.
Feet first.
That's going to be like you're supposed
to stop.
It's like kicking a fighter when their
arms are down kind of thing.
It's a rough time.
Like I know that they changed the rule
recently,
but I'm sort of same kind of thing where
he hit that dude.
Even though the dude was already down,
the guy went down on his own accord.
He lets him sliding feet first.
I mean he's not supposed to be hitting
him like that.
He should know better is what that is.
Why everyone was mad.
That's why these coaches yelling.
He just took a cheap shot at him.
Yeah,
exactly.
And he hit him really hard,
knocked him right out of the game.
So what happens to that guy?
Forty seven.
He gets a fine.
Yeah.
That dude's spread that for three or
four games.
He got his bell rung.
Yeah.
That's a fucked up thing,
right?
In College football.
They're taking them.
They're taking them out of the game
right away.
He would have been probably thrown
directly out of the game,
potentially.
Ms Dot Moore,
maybe half the next game.
And so they give a penalty to the other
team.
Yeah.
So in the NFL right now it's just a
penalty.
Football referees are on the take.
How many of these guys get busted?
Like that's a big thing about NBA
players.
I was reading this whole thing about how
little NBA players make and how they're
constantly watched all these MBA or not
mba players,
NBA referees,
me and other watching all these players
pull up and bentleys and rolls royces
and shining with diamonds and gold and
jewelry and that these guys just start
taking bribes and that there is one
point in time where there's just a
shitload of referees in the NFL and the
NBA that are just on the take and they,
they'll get bribed by bookies.
They'll get bribed by people that are
big time gamblers.
And you've got to think,
if this guy's only making,
I mean,
how much does a referee make?
So somewhere between anywhere between
150 and 500,000.
That's a good living with someone comes
to you.
If you make 115,
someone comes to me,
he goes,
Joey,
just want you to make this game a little
bit more easy for the dolphins.
Here's a hundred acres.
How much they make per group per year.
And some players there make that per
game.
Now pull up,
um,
bribery in NBA referees or corruption.
And NBA referees,
it's been a bunch of guys that had been
busted.
Right?
I don't know about a bunch.
I think it's really just the one guy,
just one.
He tried to call out a bunch of other
people,
but he didn't do it by name,
who I talked to them.
That guy did.
You guys know shit.
What'd he say?
He's a good guy.
He's just a fucking listen.
You fall into that trap.
They have so many scams.
Like he was telling me they got like the
first class tickets,
shit [inaudible],
you know,
where they give you a first class ticket
to travel to a games is so much.
Just a little bit of this,
a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
you know.
Well there was always a lot of that with
boxing as well in college basketball,
just like this is a tremendous coaches
and some different programs and I think
it was adidas might've been.
So they were playing.
Families were getting paid through the
shoe companies to direct players to
certain schools and then they were
getting signed by those companies when
they made it to the NBA.
And in some cases,
I think Rick Pitino,
who the coach for Louisville is taking
something like 98 percent or 95 percent
of the money that was due to the school
from Adidas.
He was just keeping it all.
What?
Yeah,
what?
No,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
Legal is a weird word on that.
I mean it's in the contract and it was
like cash and paying him basically.
Yes.
If you go back to the movie blue chips,
which came out a long time ago,
it's all being.
It was like fictional then,
but it's been going on for the last $25.
Why would they pay him?
Like what do they,
what do they get if adidas wants to like
what,
what does the deed is get out of it?
He's bringing in the most popular
players that are going to be like most
popular recruits from highschool and Aau
and so that maybe he could bring them to
adidas and then Adidas.
You have them all in the final for the
NCAA tournament.
They're going to be on Saturday
basketball.
They're getting advertised just like NBA
players,
but they're not getting the money.
They're getting their names in lights,
you know,
they're all over sports center,
so they essentially would adidas would
pay him to be an influencer.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's weird.
That's a weird role.
So he would be the father figure or the
coach figure to these young men.
They look up to him.
He's a mentor in some ways on it.
Yeah,
definitely.
And he wheezes them into the adidas fold
and data what they want that they want
to wear.
Adidas cluff stuff.
Yeah.
They want that.
The cool jerseys.
They're make Ohio state right now.
The team I'm pay pay attention to for
football,
have some awesome crazy jerseys that
nobody's ever going to get that like the
Lebron James Brand of Nike is giving
them that are going to be showcased all
over TV Saturday.
I was reading it
about under armour is banking on Steph
Curry's new under armour shoe.
Good luck.
Oh Wow.
Jamie so much.
There were saying that steph curry,
who's like one of the best players in
the league,
apparently you know that more than I do,
I don't know shit about basketball.
They were saying that his new under our
Mushu there,
they're putting a lot of money into this
idea that his shoe is going to rebound
the stock.
So people are making recommendations to
buy under armour stock now so that when
the shoe comes out,
everybody gets crazy and buys his shoe
and then under armour will bounce back.
Um,
you know,
the problem is once,
once something has a stink about it,
that's kind of it,
you know,
that is that bad looking in my opinion.
And from knowing what I know about
sneakers,
that's not shoe that's going to bring
them back.
Why?
What's wrong with that shoe?
I lost a bunch of kids are into it,
which I don't know that they would be.
It's more about marketing.
So you have to get a whole bunch of kids
into buying that.
And then there's got to be a couple of
influencers in the like Mba,
video game world,
and uh,
like the youtube blogging world that are
going to have to make this seem cool to
them.
Was the influence.
What does it say Steph curry on it?
Is that 30 is number?
Oh,
it looks like an SC,
doesn't it?
I mean,
I guess I wouldn't wear these shoes is
all.
I have so much fucking money in the
sneaker business.
You wouldn't wear those shoes.
You wear those goofy looking yeezys.
I also like,
I wouldn't wear these casually.
I'm not playing basketball.
Do you need a tissue?
So if some people might be wearing this
for basketball,
there are a lot of kids still playing
basketball.
If they can get a team into buying them,
then you get 15 pairs sold that to a
team and you're talking about two
totally different worlds,
right?
You're talking about there's people that
buy shoes to wear to play in casual or.
And then there's people that buy shoes
just to hang out in.
Correct?
Yep.
And they're doing them.
They're buying athletic shoes for
hanging out purposes.
Right.
And these,
the marketing of it is a real weird
place because Jordan's are where it all
started.
Michael Jordan got everybody wearing
shoes,
you know?
Yeah.
And Jordan's people don't play
basketball and Jordans,
correct or no?
They don't.
Yeah,
they don't do it because you look cool
when you were a Jew.
You're wearing those fucking cool
Jordan's.
Yeah.
Oh.
So if you wear Jordan's playing
basketball,
like this guy is so fucking crazy.
He's playing basketball and George or
even.
Yeah,
like he's playing basketball and that
thousand dollar Retro Jordans that cost
a thousand dollars.
Some of them do.
Oh wait.
Yes,
really?
I mean brand new retail.
They're costing about 100 to 200.
Not 100,
200 bucks retail.
But the rarity of them,
especially depending on the year they
came out,
if they came out five years ago,
they,
some of them cost a thousand bucks,
2000 bucks.
Not to associate with geese or whatever.
I get like a cheap g take out those
shoulder roll.
What do you call those show role?
Yeah.
People wait on line for those limit.
They made a Michael Jordan won.
They made them a guy that don't do
Jujitsu.
They put a gay out of Michael Jordan g
that they sold in Chicago.
I know a guy that buys all those skis,
like they do the same thing,
like lucky limited time.
Only midnight.
They have hundreds of geese.
Do not wear really just the shoulder
rolls to show you rose.
I don't know exactly what they gained
that I don't fucking know.
I like that Dr Stuff.
Yeah,
those are great that that.
That gives you still wear it.
It is nice.
It's.
It's real durable too because the hemp
is just so much more durable than
cotton.
It's just those things.
I mean,
keys are pretty.
God Damn durable as it is.
It usually takes a long time for one
starts to break.
Unless you have a single.
We've,
you know,
one of
those thin light ones.
Summer food chips.
Great.
I love just doing all the mats for.
Are they?
Yeah.
Love food.
Geez.
I got the white one.
The black one that you could pull them.
I'm a gorilla in that thing,
but they.
I knew I wouldn't.
This is why I knew I wouldn't do well in
hot yoga.
First of all,
I'm not.
I eat guy.
You could tell how I even humidity.
I don't respond well to.
When I first started Jujitsu,
that was the biggest problem I had that
I didn't know anything about geese,
so I went and bought a Judogi.
That heat,
that heat level went all the way up.
That took me to a different place.
Yeah,
those double weave ds,
like those things.
Those are very heavy,
but some people liked that.
They liked the double weave.
They like the feeling of security of
having that very thick cloth around
them.
Some people like that golden weave.
I like the single.
We've this summer,
the fucking thing.
I want it to feel light.
I don't want to fucking get.
You don't look at the size of me.
If I put again,
it's 20 pounds,
but also for me,
I.
I've been.
How about staff a couple times,
so I always put a rash guard on anyway.
Even if I were a rash guard on,
I just don't see people get scratched
from fingernails all the time and I also
carried those defense soap,
the white spray,
the soap.
I got the soap in the shower,
put them on my fucking feet,
my drink.
Do you drink Kombucha?
That's so good.
Again,
probiotics.
Do you ever have Kimchi?
Kimchi.
That's where she can't tell shit.
Smells fucking disgusting.
I love that stuff.
Even though it says I'm Asian,
the fucking thing.
I buy a fucking jar that shit like a 32
ounce jar and I eat most of the Jones
Kimchi.
Like a fucking cabbage.
It's pickled cabbage.
It's fermented cabbage from Korea.
You fart smell worse than they'll clean
the paint off your fucking car.
Fucking Christ.
I like to camp the juice.
I just can't deal with other shit.
All that stuff is good for you.
I don't do the Greek yogurt or regular
yogurt.
Greek yogurt.
Tastes like ass.
Fuck that.
I tried the Vanilla,
the Plain Greek yogurt.
No,
I like the Dan.
I like all the other ones.
You know.
Well,
over the last few months I've been
shying away from from dairy.
I've been,
I'll eat a little cheese every now and
then because I like cheese,
but I've been trying to eliminate dairy
from my diet a little bit just to see
because I've heard from several people
that they've eliminated dairy and
they've had good reactions.
Their body,
they fed like less inflammation and it
makes them feel better.
I'm that shit that sending that report.
I'm lactose intolerant.
I don't drink milk.
I drink a milkshake once a month.
I'll drink a milkshake and make a banana
shake at home or something like that.
My shakes then,
so I think that's what I'm going to do
for November.
I'm trying to figure out what I'm going
to do for November,
but I think for November I'm going to go
the entire month without eating any
bullshit.
One hundred percent the entire month.
Just all healthy food.
No added sugar?
No,
no nothing.
No Sodas,
no crap.
I'm just going to see what that feels
like.
I'm just saying we gotta we're going to
come up with some new challenge because
after this month doing this,
I feel like this was a very beneficial
month for me.
Beneficial in that first of all,
my back has never felt better.
Like doing yoga all these times.
Like it makes your backfield
bulletproof.
Like you just feel like my posture and
everything.
Like everything is just.
It feels so sturdy because yoga,
especially [inaudible] like that 90
minute hot yoga shits.
So much of it is about your back and
your core and like supporting your
spine.
And I think,
uh,
you know,
sitting down a lot doing podcast even
though these chairs are phenomenal,
these Pisco Ergo depot chairs,
these things are phenomenal.
They keep you sitting in the right
posture and their support.
You well,
she's not real good to sit down all the
time like that.
And a lot of times your back is
compressed and if you don't have good
structure and if you don't have good
strength around the spine,
like good muscle strength around the
spine,
you're going to develop all sorts of
weird problems and weird,
weird issues with your back.
But I think um,
I've learned a lot and this month about
like what,
what kind of exercises you need to do to
keep your back strong,
you know,
like this yoga shit,
like doing it as many times as we did it
this month.
I mean,
I'm not going to do it this many times,
but I'm definitely going to do it two
times a week from now on.
Definitely because if you mix it with
the weights,
a little run and you can,
can go,
Yep,
you're good to go.
You don't need much if we're not going
to the Olympics.
Right.
We're not fucking trying to maintain,
to maintain.
Keep your fucking whatever going.
That's all.
It's not a lot.
Have you ever done the cryotherapy?
Cryotherapy,
the cold shit.
Yeah.
I worked myself up,
but it's right around the corner from my
house.
Have you done it?
No,
I just always forget to go down.
It's phenomenal.
I think I had a lot of problems.
You know,
I wrote A.
I wrote the fucking whatever the first
four chapters for the book.
For your book.
Yeah,
that's what I did.
August and September.
Which what are you writing a book about?
What got me into comedy?
Where I got the.
Just the biography?
Yeah.
Hey,
this and that.
Finally started August first.
I got the IPAD whenever the IPAD.
We write it on an IPAD.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And I ride it.
Hire the kid and he edits everything
from me.
Oh yeah.
So I had to have four chapters done.
I got to tell you something.
So you have a book deal.
Dumb to try to join us.
Yeah.
I wanted to write it bro.
And I wanted to write.
I didn't want to say every time I had
somebody else write it.
Joey Diaz is like a floyd story.
You should have seen the last guy story
floyd story and whatever the fuck those
people have no fucking story and story.
Who's floating?
I have no fucking idea.
People,
you know,
be no writing has gotten like when you
read salad to the lands,
right?
It's just plain writing,
but sometimes you read these books with
the go a little too far with that
bullshit.
You know what I'm saying?
Like whatever.
It's just too much.
It's like you were saying you have to go
to people's houses and they talk and
then say shift for 20 minutes.
Then it's like by studio city where I
live,
go to that coffee shop from time to
time.
You know what they were saying in there
the day after the Vegas shooter,
the Vegas shooter was Sunday night.
Do you know what these idiots Hussein in
there Monday,
but that this had to do a woman's rights
and abortions and they just talk these
new lists.
No breather gentiles.
They just talk.
That's all they do is talk with big
words to impress you.
But they don't say shit.
Don't say shit.
Three or four big words to let you know
they're smart and then they didn't say
nothing and it was a lot of repeating
narratives.
Oh yeah.
Every time the show,
the new show I'm gonna do.
I'm buying one of those little tape
recorders and I'm putting them on these
six fucking morons every day.
Then at night I'm going to do a show
about what they discussed because this
is 60 percent of America with these
fucking people talking about this is the
idiots.
The shit that comes out of that mouth is
amazing and you sit there and go,
no one to fucking isis wants to shoot
us.
Listen to these fucking dummies.
Listen to what's coming out of their
mouth.
Women's rights.
That's what the total amount that the.
Well,
what was their argument?
They were saying that the guy that
argument is everybody trying to be
smarter than everybody.
It's just six people trying out with
each other.
It's like when you go to those dinner
parties you talk about,
and by the time they served the salad,
you want to put a gun in your fucking.
Why am I even fucking here with these
people?
I could have stopped at Burger King,
had a better fucking time.
That's why I don't go to those dinner
parties because it's eight people to
once politics comes up.
You loosely,
Joe Rogan.
I don't want to hear about it no more.
You lose me.
These new political people talking
nonsense,
you lose me.
Move forward.
Either impeach him,
get a new one or shut the fuck up.
I can't even put the news on it anymore,
but it's definitely 20 minutes on.
He didn't send the check.
He called her.
What the fuck man.
Just tell who gives a fuck.
Who gives a fuck?
There's got to be something more.
There's got to be a seal stuck on a
beach somewhere.
This fucking country.
Something more important than this shit
every fucking day.
So the politics is over my world.
Religion,
you know,
I don't want to.
You're not supposed to talk about
politics or religion that those fucking
things,
but this new breed of gentile,
they just talk for the sense of talking
to see who's the smartest person in the
room and at the end of the day they're
all a bunch of dumb fucks.
Anyway.
It was definitely a lot of people
talking and just impress other people.
Yeah,
that's it.
And there's a lot of people saying a
bunch of things that they've read on
blogs or read on websites.
Everybody wants to have an intelligent
conversation and everybody would he get
the fuck outta here.
Get the fuck Outta here,
man.
Leave me the fuck
alone.
Two thousand seven.
Would you rather them talk about
something that makes sense?
Something simple that you're not trying
to impress me.
Talk to me about your kids,
what you want.
There's a lot more than Hollywood
because people are trying.
I think one of the things about
Hollywood is that people are always
trying out for auditions.
They're always going in on auditions and
they're always.
They always have to be picked and chosen
and they're always trying to position
themselves like someone that you would
want to hire.
And so they manufacture these,
these attitudes based on what they
think.
They lick their finger,
they hold it up,
they find out which way the wind's
blowing and that's the way they go.
And they start to sort of construct
their personality based on what they
think.
All the casting agents,
all of them,
100 percent of them are liberal.
They're all liberal,
everyone's liberal,
everyone across the board is a democrat
or of the radical ones are Bernie
Sanders supporters and everyone has very
clear left wing views,
whether you like it or not,
not not,
not a judgment on it,
but these people that go in for
auditions and actors,
which is most of what you're running
into either actors or screenwriters or
someone who's trying to do something in
Hollywood.
They all want people to know that
they're on the right team and they all
want to say all the things that they
think need to be said.
Where you solve a lot of the hypocrites
who was in the first few days of this
Harvey Weinstein,
please.
Yeah,
and you know what men at the end of the
week,
they're all fucked him.
Discuss those because they all fucking
knew about it.
Oh,
they all knew.
They all knew about it for years and
none of the old one that raised their
fucking been been.
What Bro?
With hobbes was given them movies.
Nobody was complaining.
Yeah.
Well,
I've.
I've heard no complaining,
no complaining from a girl.
She was saying that a Harvey Weinstein
gave them all careers.
I was like,
wow,
that's a crazy,
crazy argument.
The one or two of the chicks thanked him
in the ass because now you're going to
acute.
Listen to leave me the fuck alone.
The ones that really need the smack of
the mouth of the guys that came up and
said,
I got molested one side.
My Gut touched on the party one time.
We live for that shit.
We live for somebody to touch a fucking
Dick.
You know what I'm saying?
We're not going to go to therapy.
We don't say nothing.
Somebody grabs you dick.
He just fucking gay guy.
Whatever.
Everybody needs a break from time to
time.
You know what I'm saying?
You never met a gay Guy Sucking Dick.
What?
I know it's a party.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I don't know,
but I had a friend one time that he led.
Anybody suck his dick.
Anybody,
anybody,
anybody who wants to suck his dick did
as yum.
Yum.
Stick.
Really.
The one thing he was telling me about
fucking getting his dick sucked by a gay
guy with ice cubes in his mouth.
I nearly fucking died.
It just let the guy do it.
He goes,
fuck.
What was the conversation?
He was telling me how his mouth was cold
and all this shit and that was fucking
dying.
I couldn't believe it at the guy while
he's sucking dick or I didn't listen.
I don't want to know about that.
You would want to know,
but you wanted to know about the guy.
Get his dick sucked by a dude with ice
cubes in his mouth.
I mean,
why not?
What he told me is watching it.
First of all,
when he told me this story,
I was young.
I had never heard that story before.
I was like,
18.
He goes,
I love the fucking guy.
Suck my throat one time,
but if it was so good,
why don't I keep going know it's tough
to find somebody who will suck your Dick
with ice cubes in the muffin unless you
give them the small 50.
I think once you put it out there,
you put that flag up.
People come.
That was the funniest thing with that
crazy bitch from superman because she
popped up like eight days later.
However he took his dick out.
One time.
I tell him,
put that back in your pants and crazy
chick from superman,
which was.
What's that check?
That's crazy.
Oh,
the one that was hiding in the bushes
when they found her,
she had no teeth at one.
What the Hell is her name?
What's her name?
Superman.
Christopher Reeve,
right?
No,
the other one wasn't superman.
Christopher.
A.
The earliest superman,
right?
Yeah.
Was the one with Dean Cain who was the
Dean Cain who was the biggest killer.
Margot kidder is crazy,
right?
Yeah.
So this was the other one that you're
talking about.
The one who was in superman with Dean
Cain.
The TV show.
Was it really pretty girls name?
Teri hatcher.
Terry had her name.
She got to talk into the mic,
but she was on a TV show.
She was in desperate housewives to.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
it wasn't her.
I had an ex girlfriend might get so mad
when I was talking about how pretty she
was missing superman.
Actress found frightened into bushes.
Yeah.
That was in [inaudible] 96.
Margot kidder.
Yeah.
She went crazy.
Forty seven year old Canadian born
actress.
Best known.
You know what?
That's the thing.
Once you hit like late forties and
you're one of those actresses and they
stopped calling and your already crazy
and the pressure builds up.
She'd cut off her own hair with a razor
blade and attempt to alter her
appearance.
A Glendale Police Sargent Rick Young
said,
oh boy.
She was taken to Olive View Medical
Center for a 72 hours.
Psychiatric evaluation,
taking a spared 71 hours and 50 minutes
by just bringing her to me the way.
Yeah,
that bitch is crazy.
What happened here the other day with
Corey Feldman though?
I don't know.
He apparently had arrest.
Oh,
that thing.
Yeah.
I just,
I made a joke and people get mad.
Then they got mad,
but it wasn't them getting mad as me
getting mad at myself.
What was the Joe?
Uh,
he was wearing a really small jacket
while he's doing this performance at
like a minor league baseball game,
and he was doing like this Michael
Jackson thing and the jacket was so
small.
I go,
is that a jacket he was wearing when he
was getting diddled when he was a little
kid?
And I was like,
why did I joke around that?
It was just trying to make greg laughed.
I said something that I was.
And then afterwards when I saw it,
especially out of context,
I was very disappointed in myself.
He wants 10 million exposed.
He saw that he's out of his mind,
I think.
Um,
I don't think he,
first of all,
he never said that Michael Jackson did
anything to him.
He was,
he said Michael Jackson didn't.
But he said that there's a lot of
pedophilia in Hollywood.
He wants to make some sort of a movie on
it,
which I'm sure there's a lot of
pedophilia in Hollywood,
but like this idea that people are
trying to kill him.
You were saying people trying to run
them over and someone.
Isn't that what we're saying?
I watched the video for the hearts and
seconds.
I felt bad for my kids.
If they wanted to kill him,
he'd be dead.
Yet he tried to hit him.
That's not real.
See,
this is like weird paranoid as shit.
Let me tell you something.
If they want to kill you,
you're dead and it's not going to be
trucks trying to run you over.
It's going to be a guy out of nowhere,
shoots you in the head and gets in his
car and no one's going to know who he is
and no one's going to catch them because
they're going to hire a professional.
Like this idea that someone's gonna like
miss him with a car and then they're
chasing them or running them down.
I find that very hard.
I mean it's possible,
but I find it very hard to believe.
I always think that like if someone is a
very powerful man,
like,
like I don't know if the Clintons ever
whacked anybody,
but if they did,
they whack those fucking people.
Like that one guy.
That was the big,
the big conspiracy theory about the guy
who released all this stuff.
To wiki leaks of the DNC guy,
seth rich.
Yeah.
They killed that motherfucker.
Whoever did it,
whether he was killed because some
random person decided to shoot him in
the back in the middle of the night and
not steal his watch or his phone or his
wallet,
whether it's that or whether it's what
Julian assange's from Wiki leaks said is
that there's consequences to leaking
information to wikileaks because that's
what they were saying and people were
saying,
look,
this is another one of the Clinton body
count people and then this giant
conspiracy theories about how many
people the Clinton's have had killed.
I don't know if that's true or not.
I have zero information,
but I do know when people want you dead,
you're dead.
You're dead.
When they're real people like that that
are real killers and evil fucks.
There's a lot of people that have been
killed like Putin.
If Putin wants you dead,
you get shot on TV in front of everybody
and nothing happens.
No one goes to jail.
No one gets caught.
You're just dead.
That's the type of people we're talking
about.
So this,
you know,
just have a hard time believing that
like someone's getting like barely
missed by a car that's like some movie
shit,
like they were coming after me but I
lived in the bushes at the last minute
and now I'm hiding in a motel somewhere
and I can't tell you where.
But if you give me $10,000,000,
I want to make a movie.
I feel bad for corey from when you see
that,
when you see that performance.
But he's a nice kid and stuff.
You could see holly was just made a
mockery.
Like they just beat him up though.
Well he grew up on TV and the media,
they'd beat them up.
Roll up in the movies.
You,
you,
you don't have a childhood.
Who the fuck do you know who at named
one that made it through that meat
grinder of growing up famous.
That's not completely fucking crazy.
Name one name one.
Miley Cyrus might've got out of it
better than any of them.
She's like her new album's really good.
Great Bro.
Don't use those ones that she's up on
the hill and kind of see what the little
band and this thing of that side of the
mountains.
Every cover of Jolene,
jolene,
Jolene,
that whole thing.
Although she's great.
I've always liked it.
She got a little something that we can
tell them.
No,
we played.
We played some of it before.
Yeah.
She fucking.
Once you started talking about no reef
fucker.
I used to see at the store all the time,
but when her brother at the weed store,
she was smoking more than anybody.
Now she quit whatever.
20.
Yeah.
She's 23.
She's talking shit.
She's a kid.
She's fucking got more money than God.
I want to show.
I would watch the show on the road.
Hannah Montana Hall please.
Your kids like it.
I loved that fucking show.
I love her and that show.
She's tremendous.
Yeah.
Play some of that.
Give me some of that with our Internet
really.
Well.
That's good.
It's not like we paid a shitload of
money.
Have you seen.
Have you seen John Wick two was right?
We just watched that.
Like it's entertainment.
It's not going to win an academy award
and loved it,
but if you think about how many hip men
like that scene in the train station,
that chick with the violin and also she
puts the thing away and she takes a
silencer out.
Did you see Eagleton that you get
Machado?
I watched it twice and I haven't seen
him know.
He gives this bar too.
He plays a cab driver so they can think
about this.
The fight he had the garage with the cab
drive is when he was fucking shooting at
him and all that shit nasty,
fucked mighty mouse is.
Um,
how about Joe wicks on board and that's
where the shock to the head with a
bullet to the head,
his arm bar,
he clamps shit.
He drops back and he goes by,
he lifts your head with his foot dot.
That's the fucking mighty mouse picking
up the guy.
Fuck Ray Berg.
That fucking arm bar that he does a
board.
Great Burger.
You know what I realized in your,
your phone,
your computer is a
having problems with the Internet.
Mine is not.
My computer is not have one.
I just switched out routers,
routers,
it's the,
it's the Wifi router.
Oh,
you were on.
So that was on Wifi and then you went to
ether net.
Is that what you do?
Switching back and forth,
but.
Oh,
I see.
So who trains them for reals?
Joe Rogan.
Well he's obviously got a Machado,
a jacket on,
so it must have been doing some.
But I'll tell you what,
like all the Jujitsu moves and the judo
was 100 percent legit.
Like there was no like shenanigans,
like you see him throw somebody around
and you don't believe it.
Like even his front kick.
That's a legit front kick.
Look,
he's doing real shit.
You know what else he did?
That was real.
He did a lot.
Look at,
he's doing all this fucking strength and
conditioning,
footwork,
moving.
He's doing all these roles.
Another thing that he did that was super
real was he did a lot of tactical
firearms drills,
like a lot of close range handgun shit.
Whereas,
you know,
shooting at a steel targets that pop up
and hiding behind things and turning
corners and shooting at targets real
quick,
like legitimately looks like he
knows what he's doing.
Okay.
Have you ever had a chat with him?
I've never met him.
Tremendous.
I bet he eats breakfast.
Had Dukes,
Hollywood on the way out.
You just go.
What's up Dawg?
Nigga?
What's happening man?
Have a great day.
Yeah.
This is the shit that he did.
There's a whole video of him going
through these tactical courses and
you're like,
whoa,
that's legit.
Like he's.
He's putting in the time.
Matthew three.
Fucking looks great for 53,
53.
That's crazy.
It looks great.
It looks fucking great.
That's a good Kamora.
Yeah.
See,
like he's rolling.
What is he up?
That's not a black belt,
is he?
No,
he's white belt.
He a white belt with a black stripe.
They do is.
They have a facility.
You see this facility where they just
redid this and culver city.
The Machados do.
That's Hagen.
The company,
the one eight,
seven,
whatever the name of that company is his
company production company.
So they have everything that like most
companies you go to,
they have a couch and screens and shit.
No,
this is what.
I don't think this is the place they
have like a real fucking place where
they do all stars.
And that was that John over there?
Yeah.
John,
John Keegan Johns.
They're all the Machados,
but all this stuff that he's doing is
like super legit.
There's Hagan.
I mean he's,
he's really.
He really wanted to learn Jujitsu.
Like he learned a real Jujitsu as
opposed to just make it up some fake
moves and shit though is odd ball with a
bullet at the end is fucking beautiful
fun movies.
They're fun,
ridiculous,
sort of cartoonish violent movements.
It's really good times lately.
The hills itself,
self fucking crazy.
Well who's the girl to that?
Is that sort of androgynous lesbian
character who's in a lot of stuff?
Orange is the new black.
Is that who she is?
She's very pretty.
She's got short hair.
She's the hit woman in the movie.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
She plays the deaf girl.
Deaf girl.
Yeah,
because you play the deaf girl and one
was the John Wick two.
Now she's the person and she's the
killer that wanted to kill him.
The fuck's her name.
Did she kills herself?
Is that the chick that kills us up now?
She doesn't kill herself.
Her just show me the fucking imd be.
No,
that's not it.
What's the uh,
who uh,
who was in the room?
Ruby rose.
That one?
Yeah.
That chick,
you know,
she's real famous lesbian type
character.
She plays,
she's a death in the movie.
I don't remember if member she has like
this and she's telling them that she
wanted a nightcap and shit.
She's always,
she speaks sign language in the movie or
why did I,
how did I forget that?
Stopped smoking weed that it was so
broad sober.
I'm just watching people get shot.
I'm not paying attention to the actual
plot.
It's just a fun,
stupid moment.
I love them both.
That's a weird.
I love him.
I like all his fucking movies,
man.
There's just some people that he watched
movies on need to think.
Yeah,
well he's,
he's got some classics.
I mean,
think about the John Wick series.
He's in the Matrix.
I mean,
this dude has been in some fucking
classics and bill and Ted's excellent
adventure.
You go back to that.
I mean,
imagine that that guy started with like
a really silly comedy and then went from
that to be a giant action hero and
somehow or another still looks good at
53.
What's that movie he made with the bank
robbers that they fucking great big
points of the movie to movie Patrick
swayze.
Fucking good movie too.
Yeah.
I want to know what Keanu reeves does to
reduce stress because he looks fucking
fantastic.
I look at him.
Look,
he's never in trouble.
You would never hear from him in a bar.
We're drinking or drinking wine while
hanging out with no body or abused.
He don't do Dick.
He grows his beard out.
He walks around looking dirty.
When you see them in the daytime and
it's just a regular guy like what is he
doing?
Has He looked so good?
He's just a regular guy,
but I said no trouble.
I know,
but like I wonder like what he eats
because someone told me that he actually
smoked cigarettes.
Like that is not like particularly
like disciplined about his health.
That's incredible.
Ninety four to 2014.
How's that even possible?
Imagine if you ran into one of his ex
girlfriends.
He looks exactly the same.
She was like an old hag.
She's like,
what the fuck?
I mean that's 20 years of difference and
he looks the same.
Well he looks like shit.
And the 2013 no,
2012,
2013 was a rough turn one that fell off
the road.
Well that's where they met here and
everything changed.
His life fucking changed.
He started the podcast.
He called me up to go down there on
what?
On some network that should maybe learn
English first or no,
it doesn't matter.
They love him anyway.
They love him smoking cigarettes.
So he does smoke cigarettes.
You see,
that's even crazier.
Like how is he not old as fuck?
Like when people smoke cigarettes,
that shit wears you out.
Like the people that I see that smoke
cigarettes,
they look far older than he is.
You couldn't.
That mean that people think there's like
pictures they find where he was like,
oh,
can I read was from the 1750,
whatever.
Yeah.
People retarded.
They photoshop the shit out of that
anyway.
Right.
So I watched some crazy shit last night.
Joe Rogan.
I didn't feel good.
I couldn't move much.
I lost the remote and I started watching
this thing about the story that really
fucking tremendous.
The reels,
it's called real a real news or
something that's 2:39
on cable and they had this whole thing
out about the godfather.
Fucking interesting as Fuck Jack.
What was interesting about.
What's his name?
They want to do the movie.
The director.
He was a hippie and San Francisco.
I had a studio up there.
What's his name?
Francis Ford Coppola is a Hippie Guinea.
He ain't regular.
He's Hippie long tenured.
Huh?
He owns a vineyard.
Hippie dude had the studio and they
wanted him to do the godfather and he
was like,
ah.
But he had an assistant called.
What's his sister's name?
A George Lucas was a young assistant,
really?
That was his young assistant at the
time.
That's crazy that he talked him into it
because he goes at the building they had
was running out of money.
They had no money to pay the rent.
Wow.
We're going to run out of the rent,
so he talked them into doing it because
he had to pay the rent.
Look at that.
George Lucas and Francis Ford Coppola
with r two D two.
That's incredible.
Kids like 24 years old.
Young kids,
Bro.
Y'All kids.
I'll tell you what was a good move that
a lot of people were critical of when
they sold star wars to Disney because
Disney is taking that shit and run with
it.
They run with it.
I mean they're making so many more star
wars movies.
They're good fucking movies.
They're fun.
They're doing star wars world at
Disneyland,
which looks insane.
They released a preview video of it the
other day.
Have you taken your girl to a Disneyland
yet?
No,
she hasn't asked.
You just said,
I'll just wait.
I'm done.
She hasn't.
She asked about a month ago.
Tell me when you want to go and we'll go
together.
Okay.
Yeah.
She.
She asked about a month ago.
We go together.
It's just stopped getting sick,
bro.
Oh really?
Just got over it.
Yeah,
that's why I'm not doing new year's
week.
You know that shit because we'll go a
little.
Wait.
Does she look out the window?
How is she not get car sick?
Keeps her from getting.
We leave early and I don't feed her.
We take her out of the house.
Fucking soldier style.
Oh,
that's good.
And we only go one hour,
so that's why we went to Huntington
beach.
We go to Santa Barbara,
so that's what I'm gonna do on those
little holidays now.
That's good.
Just getting the fuck out of here.
I'm sick and tired of sitting here for
Thanksgiving.
Yeah,
take it down and they have eaten beets.
I get the Nice hotel for kids.
Drop them off at eight.
They serve.
You could have the walk to the fucking
beach for them to have to walk on the
street and then I'll go up to month to
see though what I'm familiar.
I love it up there.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's it,
bro.
Go but come back from Portland that
Friday.
I come back that Thursday.
That Friday I'm doing two shows after
Christmas.
Get back and I'm taking them up the
month to see though to the second.
There's nothing to do down here.
Not The dope.
The dope.
Have you thought about moving out of
here?
Just waiting.
Just waiting for one for another year.
Another year.
Were you thinking of going?
I don't know.
It's Colorado or Lexington?
Kentucky,
Huh?
Yeah.
There's a lot of people here.
Joey Diaz seems like it's getting worse
to do.
The thing that freaks me out is the
eminent doom that one day for sure the
earth's going to move.
The fucking water pipes are going to
break.
Fire's gonna break out.
It's for sure we're going to have a
disaster and when we have a disaster,
then we're going to realize the real
consequences of jamming 20 million
people into a small area.
That bothers me with all of this was
going on this summer as the two or three
weeks you'd watch the news.
When you think of that like we got to be
next.
We're sitting here in a cozy fucking
warm living room with watching Florida
underwater Texas on the water.
You know what?
What's going to come to us?
Well,
the fires in northern California,
we're fucking insane.
Hardly anybody talked about him.
It's not a ton of people living up
there,
so people did.
It didn't get the amount of press that
it deserved because there was so much
going on in Texas,
so much going on in Florida.
So much going on in Puerto Rico,
but the fucking fires in northern
California were insane and they couldn't
do anything about them.
They didn't have fire hydrants and a lot
of these places,
they didn't have access to water and
they were just burning through towns.
I think they said hundreds of people are
missing and thousands of buildings were
burned to the ground and it barely made
the news.
Fucking Puerto Rico is still with
without.
Oh yeah,
they're fucked.
They're fucked.
And they're not getting any funding and
you know,
how come they don't get the funding?
They've got some.
I mean it's not that they're not getting
funny,
but then they're not getting enough to
rebuild.
To do what they need to do to get their
infrastructure back on the stand about
Puerto Rico is that you have someone and
be a host on one and two that what
surrounds these cities is what you see
on tv is he's fucking village.
You know?
Did you read the New York Times article
about Cuba?
Know about the hurricane,
how good they are with hurricanes?
No.
You gotta read that article.
Were practicing this shit since 1950.
Well they have to.
They're a fucking.
When I called my sister,
my sister was like,
it was pretty nice.
We got killed.
He got killed in combat way when my
dad's from the got fucking killed.
That's still in the water,
but they don't fuck around.
They have this complete.
If you could look it up,
a New York Times article,
it was fucking huge about how they have
the hurricane.
How did they handle it?
Community.
They have a.
They fucking the.
What's that?
When they pull you out,
if I can pull you out right away.
I mean they just like you didn't hear
about Cuba having a prompt.
Now they got killed,
but they are so used to it.
They have such a great system for
dealing with it.
The only have.
There you go hurricane tips from.
There you go.
Unbelievable.
How good is that right there.
The water hitting molecule.
Look at that.
They got a 19 fifties car and the water
is like fucking 80 feet in the air.
Smashing waves against the side of the
building or the side of the road rather.
Cool.
Is that.
That's pretty bad car.
How cool is that?
They take those cards and they put like
four cylinder diesels in them too.
They do all kinds of crazy shit with
Shannon.
Did you watch that show when they did
it?
The 13 episodes of the Cuban cause now,
but I've seen a lot of things on.
Are they interesting how they fucking
paint them and all that shit that they
get like tar and put the car together.
Pretty interesting shit.
There was a,
a guy who bought an island,
uh,
outside of,
Cuba.
I forget what island it was,
but it it got hit so bad by the
hurricane that it completely wiped off
everything on the island.
This guy,
some billionaire character,
bought the entire island and for the
first time in over 300 years,
it's unpopulated.
There's literally no one living on this
island.
It went from being this green,
lush Ireland to be in just a big flat
patch of dirt like flattened.
It just got hit by the full brunt of the
storm right after this dude bought it.
I mean it.
I don't know how much you spent on it
except Richard Branson's island.
I don't think so.
No,
no.
I think it was the guy who owns a John
Paul Mitchell.
Nectar island completely.
Oh,
nobody noticed using ad blocking.
Sir Richard Branson says nectar island
completely and utterly devastated by
Hurricane Irma.
Irma.
Yeah.
It's A.
I'm sure that island got jack two,
but there was an island that is
completely unpopulated for the first
time in 300 years.
I forget what the island was,
but these are just going to get worse.
That's the crazy thing about these
hurricanes is they're building up steam
out in the ocean versus in the Gulf,
like usually they would get to the Gulf
and they would build up because the Gulf
has warmer water,
but the water and the ocean is getting
so warm that the island of Barbuda I
don't think.
Yeah,
that's it.
I don't think somebody owns that one.
No,
someone just bought it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Some guy just bought the island of
Barbuda Amish.
Something to think.
So you be thinking about labor?
Yes.
Now I think about leaving all the time.
Yeah.
What been discussing?
You open it up when it was getting a
100,
nine degrees in fucking October.
We were like,
what is this going to be like in five
years?
Like is this keep going to keep getting
worse?
Like if climate change is real,
it seems to be.
If we're getting record temperatures
every year,
which seems to be happening at least
around here.
You gotta wonder like when that's not
sustainable anymore.
When you do you want to live in Phoenix
in August?
I don't you know that that Phoenix
weather we've been there before,
120 degrees.
That's not,
that's not dealable to me.
You know that Robert Deniro vows to
rebuild the island of Barbuda after
Hurricane Irma strikes.
Why is it filled with black checks now?
He owns a year before.
I guess he bought a resort there.
Jamie's taking it all.
Literally.
No,
no,
that's fine.
Oh my God.
Give a c.
When they did the,
the,
the fucking benefit for him.
They did the tribute to Robert Deniro.
No,
I'm beyond.
Say got it there with a fucking
miniskirt and stole dancing.
Poor Robert Deniro.
He go crazy.
Oh my God.
You could see them just melting,
like looking at dogs.
He loves.
He loves the sisters.
He does.
Can't be mad at him for that.
It's kind of interesting.
Is there another guy that's known for
love and black chicks as much as deniro
is?
No,
no,
no.
He's like known for it where you crack
jokes about it and everybody knows the
joke,
right?
Like it's known for,
but nobody really says no.
It's deniro give them same.
Well,
I mean it's not,
that's just flavor,
but it's an obvious flavor.
It's like,
I mean,
I can't even think of a single celebrity
that's like known for having a
predilection for Asian chicks.
Name one.
Okay.
Name another celebrity that's got a
thing for,
uh,
for black checks.
Deniro.
It's Zinnia Arrows.
Did running snipes has got to think for
Asian chicks.
Vinnie,
thank.
Maybe.
Maybe,
maybe he's married to one or something.
Something,
something.
Yeah,
but not enough where like you could tell
a joke about it,
like Deniro was one of those guys were
like,
a piece of information has to be so far
distributed,
so widely distributed that you can crack
jokes about it and everybody knows what
you're talking about.
Like that's like the Dinero thing.
It's gotten to the point where anybody
could crack a joke about it.
Did you prefer any particular woman type
Dayton?
No.
White chicks?
Yeah.
I love white chicks.
Terry white chicks.
Love them,
love them,
love them.
Chinese.
I like dirty white chicks.
Yeah,
I love 5:30.
I don't know,
just something as a kid.
I liked the Irish checks.
I grew up in a place where I was
surrounded with Shakespearian freckles
and red hair and sweaty tits.
I love all that shit.
You know,
I don't like dirty feet,
but I like when white chicken feet.
I like blank checks,
you know,
they say when you're a kid,
like the things you are surrounded by,
the things that like you first come in
contact with when you become sexually
active at that,
that sort of like some cemented in your
brain and a lot of people,
but I don't all those marines and all
those.
Gina's.
I can't deal with facebook ads is they
get gene is.
Yeah.
They want to fight and shit.
They scream at you and throw shit.
That was something about that that I
liked them.
They were hotter than fuck.
I love Italian woman,
you know,
but I really like white chicks.
Irish chicks is my shit.
I love him.
I fucking love to.
Just like I have a friend that's Jewish
and that's all he dates his black
checks.
You don't really have from the Sopranos.
Yes.
What was the old man?
He goes,
I don't know if you look a little Pale
for my taste.
It's just some people.
I have a buddy,
same thing,
Jewish guy.
Love,
love,
love.
That's all marriages second black chick.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
Yeah.
You know that guy that's a.
and it's funny because you think,
uh,
like a black arrow.
He's an older guy,
you know,
he was around.
I could just imagine the first time they
ever went home,
brought a black chick home.
This does like,
what the fuck is going on there?
Know?
Well maybe not as dad,
but how about all those fucking people
that loved when those movies,
all those [inaudible] now probably
racist and then love them and all these
expected him to be with some fucking
mafia looking lady and he shows up with
some super soul sister.
Well,
that's why I fucking bronx tale was so
good.
He really put that part of his life and
they're like that part with the black
chick.
You know,
that kid that went to jail.
That's what bronx tale was about.
Really?
It was a body.
Remember that movie?
Yeah,
it was about a bronx tale is a good
fucking movie and then we just,
I hated the movie theater when I went to
see it.
I didn't like it.
I,
it wasn't for me,
but that was on a couple of weeks ago.
That same with the bikers.
That's a great fucking scene and that's
a true story.
That's a true fucking store.
This old school,
Sammy the bull story,
but your bike is willing to his bar,
Sam,
he came back and told them to be cool.
No clock the door and said no,
you can't leave.
And they just beat you.
Ever seen that?
They just beat the fuck out of all those
bikers and they get out of there.
But that movie was about the kid that
was on the sopranos that ended up going
to prison for murder.
Well,
it's just cultural.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's this,
uh,
Larry's with the guy with bad luck.
His name was marsh,
so they put them in the closet.
They wouldn't even,
I don't want his money touching my
money,
so bad luck.
But that whole thing is about him,
the date and the black.
Jake.
And then they go to the member,
was that that street in the Bronx where
I used to get nickel bags,
whatever avenue off that,
all that shit up there so it adds in a
black neighborhood so he would have to
walk home.
And then when on the walk home is for
friends,
went into the black neighborhood with
the car and they got blown up.
They got to watch this movie again.
It's a good movie man.
That chazz Palminteri guy.
He did a lot of shit and then he kind of
vanished.
Like he's still around.
He's doing this shit and Broadway now.
What's he doing?
The Bronx Tale on Broadway.
He just took it out to say he took it
out into new musical.
Get even with the gay community.
Look at their narrow.
And who's the guy on the left?
That's the gay guy who tell a bronx
tale.
Yeah.
This is a good movement.
Bizarre,
bizarre.
Remember this guy lived at your boys and
they used to go home at night and tell
stories every night.
So those guys are pissed because they
said supposedly took some of their
stories.
Frankie Renzulli,
most of his stories from East Boston,
I actually wound up in this movie,
so he did a,
they,
they kinda have residual.
He was the kind of the Sopranos.
Right.
And he realized he's written for a lot
of things.
Yeah.
But that world,
that world of guineas and mob movies and
mob stuff,
it's just like,
it becomes,
it's like an identity and a weird
business.
It's like an identity that they put
this,
you know,
the connected Italian character
identity,
you know,
and like from the soprano's on that
became a big selling point in Hollywood.
Like it was a niche that people got
excited about.
Like the Italian gangster movie became a
big thing.
The Italian gangster films became a big
thing and so there was like a whole
bunch of guys,
like I'm sure you went out for auditions
and you around those guys that were in
that loop.
It's a dumb little dumb loop.
It's hilarious.
It really is.
Well,
well they were talking about less but
like the sopranos killed a Mafia TV
show.
That's it.
You won't see the movie again for 10
years because there were so good.
Yeah,
it just covered too many of the bait.
You've never seen it again.
Every once in awhile I got the script
for a mob where they want you to go
refill this.
I opened it up and if I see Gino baby or
Tony or Angelo,
I closed a script because you're living
in a fucking fools paradise.
It's not going to get made,
which is not going to do nothing.
You got to come and that's why they
haven't been able to figure out the
posts.
The prattle world.
Right.
It was too much.
They got into the Columbus.
They even got into Columbus Day.
That's how brilliant a fucking sopranos.
What they did an episode about Columbus
Day when they sent people down there and
Nick Depalo played the cop and.
Oh yeah.
Do you remember,
remember that soprano started off as a
comedy?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Sopranos started off.
The first episode was over the top
comedy where,
what's her name?
Ed Falco was outside with an AK 47
because her daughter was trying to sneak
out.
I mean she was a cartoon character.
I mean every.
It was ridiculous,
and then slowly but surely it became
this really intense,
complicated drama and it wasn't funny at
all.
Well,
the mother died.
That changed everything.
It was the first show that somebody died
and changed the course of it because it
would've been completely different.
It would have ended with her being the
boss.
Yeah.
It would've been the first time her,
but they went back to this last night
with the Godfather,
how they had failed twice to make a mob
movie.
Kirk Douglas had done a movie in
[inaudible] 67.
It didn't do well.
So with this,
Mario Puzo was fucking.
The book was tremendous.
They sent it to.
What's his name?
They did not want Marlon Brando.
Really?
No,
they did not.
Marlon Brando had been a dud.
He had just done fucking a.
That movie,
that movie where he bought the island.
Oh,
island of Dr Moreau.
No,
no.
The one.
The big one.
When he first bought the island in 70,
68 or so when he bought his own eyes,
but he shot the movie a bounty with his
treasure.
I forget what the name of the movie is.
One Christo.
Somehow they gave a bunch of money and
go down there and shoot the movie.
He found love.
One of the natives.
So he got like the first guy,
hey jamie,
can we direct the movie?
And he started fucking raining everyday.
So paramount.
One of the,
I saw the footage,
they saw birds and people running.
They go,
what happened to our moving?
So they kinda like fucking five a brand
off from directing it mountain.
Beautifully mutiny on the bounty.
So he was done.
He was.
When he came back from the states like
he was persona non grata.
They didn't want to talk to him no more.
You fucked on money.
You left your wife for this hot chicken?
An island?
Yeah.
Ooh,
she's hot.
Yeah.
Once he met her,
he told his wife to go fuck yourself.
Go fuck themselves.
And he just started hanging out.
It goes full screen with her.
God Damn,
I get it.
Holy Shit.
That's really jet,
Huh?
Then he bought the fucking true man.
She's fucking hot.
That's some serious polynesian jeans
right there.
So when he came back,
they didn't want,
they didn't want Michael either what
they wanted they wanted,
didn't want out,
but you know what you mean.
For Michael Corleone,
they wanted a Robert Redford.
Well,
what?
Or uh,
or uh,
Ryan O'Neal.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's who they,
that's what they wanted for rocky.
That's hilarious.
That's what they want.
That answer at night from 73 to 75.
We need a black actor.
How about riding on you?
We have a boxer.
How about Ryan O'neil?
They love nails.
Look.
So they were going to put them in rocky.
You don't even hear about him anymore?
Well,
he's playing 2000 fucking years old.
What does this cat has?
Original cast lists people he had
written down for.
What were the father?
Wow.
Jimmy.
So who's,
who's,
who wrote this list?
This is a couple of hopeless.
Wow.
Corleone Marlin Brando underlined.
He wanted.
He wanted the cheeto badly.
He just did that movie about the heroin
or something.
That's an enough.
And they didn't want him.
The studio didn't want them to know.
The studio didn't want them.
He wanted them,
but the studio didn't want.
Wow,
so fucking John Saxon,
which are the plate Sunday call.
Oh,
that would've been from the enter the
Dragon Dragon.
Yeah,
like I was a good actor,
Robert Duvall for looking at that list.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
There's some movies that just even
today,
if you try to watch them there for now.
Phenomenal.
That's phenomenal.
This one's one of them.
Don't watch the one with the back
footage though.
Which ones?
That?
The one that HBO released Sunday.
He's a tree.
You could tell her bad James Collins as
an actor then.
Oh,
it's brutal.
It's brutal.
Have you seen the eight hour one now?
Hbo,
where they put them all together.
They put them all together and they put
all the pieces back in.
Really?
But you got to have a lot of times.
Eight hours.
Yeah.
It's like six hours.
It was a time for that.
You break it up into two hours segments,
but it's pretty interesting and shows
you what really happened with the father
and him
like the fall would just torture
Michael.
How you doing?
How's that little white girlfriend?
Doing a hysterical,
he was,
there's a scene in the hospital.
He pulls him over and goes,
I was that little white piece of shit,
the Patella,
and then he like,
how's those metals,
whether the shooting are you shooting
strangers and shit,
and then they go into it,
opens up with them at the wedding and
they go from the wedding to the hospital
to see the guy that originally caused
the Eddie and you got to see that same.
The dude is sitting there and I'm a
brand or walks in and he's like,
Godfather,
hold my hand.
The reapers gonna come.
But if he sees you,
he'll be scared.
Like that's how fucking much.
They loved the Godfather and then he
goes,
listen,
I'm here with my four sons.
He ain't going to bother you.
I'm here with your sons.
I'm here with my sons to pay their
respects to.
He ain't going to bother you.
Shows all that shit.
That guy that blew up his wife in
Sicily,
it shows him getting him in buffalo now.
Oh really?
The back end?
Yeah.
He owns a pizza parlor and he gets in
the car and they blow them up.
They show all that shit.
So who cut that stuff out?
The studio,
the studio.
It was too long,
you know,
don't quote me on that.
Maybe the studio,
maybe the director,
but James Caan scenes or just not to
know.
You can see he doesn't,
but Michael was fucking tough.
Michael slots,
all those dudes.
That's when directing was directing.
If you've ever done anything bad in your
life,
anything bad.
When you do something bad,
you know he is ranked.
Your ears ring or when your adrenaline
is off the charts.
When you're hiding in a bush and
somebody is coming towards you and you
got to hit them with that stick,
you have no idea what happens to you.
You have no idea.
Joe Rogan.
That's why I've always loved the
Godfather,
all those types of movies because when
he comes out of the bathroom,
you hear the train screeching key,
right?
But that's what you hear when your
department,
Bro,
when you already know.
I'm just talking about hitting somebody
in the head with a stick.
Right?
Nevermind having to come out of a
restaurant with a gun and shooting two
people.
I can't imagine where your heart go.
Wait.
Did you just get up and show people your
heart beats that adrenaline's going?
You fucking.
You don't hear nothing.
Like when I used to rob houses or rob
drug dealers,
I can't hear nothing.
You just found is going to bro.
You just go to your heart.
Takes fucking over.
You know I had this.
I forgot about this.
I had this when I was 19.
I was an electrician and Aspen,
there was a dude that used to break my
balls all the time,
like say stupid things for me.
He would always go,
there's two things about you I don't
like.
You're Cuban and you're from the east
coast.
So I always knew me and this guy,
we're going to have a little fucking
problem.
I was 19.
He was a little older than me.
I always knew man,
this motherfucker when I have a problem
and he'd always say little things to me,
go get my tools out of the bed.
And I always tell them,
go get them yourself.
Pitch.
And I was Kinda scared of that guy,
but I knew me and him,
we're going to battle one day and one
day he said something and I told him to
go fuck himself.
And when I came back from lunch,
you put a box cutter to my throat.
He got me.
As I was coming in,
he threw me against the wall and you had
the box cutter on me.
I was bigger than him physically.
And I knew I could fuck them up.
I was just scared.
I was a young kid.
I was not in my.
I was living in basalt,
Colorado,
you know,
I was not on my turf with my friends.
But after he put that knife to my
throat,
I'll never forget that.
I fucking like,
when he stepped away,
that thing came into my mind where if
you pull your gun out,
you was like,
that thing came out that.
And I go,
I'm going to fucking kill this guy.
I'm going to do something bad for this
guy.
And I had a guy who used to shoot with
that taught me how to shoot guns.
He was a Vietnam vet.
And on the weekends I would give him
money.
He teach me how to shoot everything a
and fucking ak.
He told he had every weapon.
He was just a Vietnam vet that lived in
Aspen.
And I finally figured out why they put
all those Vietnam vets around Aspen in
Colorado.
Why Norad?
Norad.
So they can be ready to fucking rock.
I never thought about that.
You know,
everybody thinks that if we get hit,
we're going to hit California,
New York,
the most strategic place that would be
wouldn't it?
Because they control everything out of
Colorado and under that fucking mountain
really lets you read up about it.
I don't know shit about that.
Yeah.
Like that was years ago.
They always said we will get hit we to
hit Colorado.
So what happened with you and the guy in
the box in the guy in the box cut.
I kept fucking like I was scared of this
guy,
Joe Rogan.
I was definitely scared of this guy.
But at that time I wanted to kill my
stepfather.
So I went to my friend,
the guy who was teaching me how to shoot
and shit.
And I told him about what happened.
He goes,
well,
if you're thinking they're shooting his
step,
father,
why don't you use this guy's practice?
Well,
what's the difference if you're going to
go back to New Jersey and struck your
stepfather and shoot them,
start with this guy.
Use them is fucking practice.
You know what I'm saying?
I was a little pushy.
I thought about it,
but I didn't like that.
The guy pulled a knife to my throat.
I fucking didn't like that.
Joe Rogan at all said I'm going to get
this guy.
So I was cool to him at work.
I let him go to work.
This went on.
I figured like get them over the
holidays.
He was a boozer and he went through this
little bar and carbondale all the time
and I figured my get him down there.
So I went to Fred,
I go teach me everything I need to do to
get this guy down.
And he goes,
we're going to get you in and out of
there as quick as possible.
And he's the first guy that ever taught
me a hanger.
You whip somebody with a fucking hanger,
it's all low.
You take the hanger,
whip it,
taped the other side and just come out
of dark with a hanger.
They don't see nothing.
All they see is this.
That's all they see.
They don't see a fucking anger.
You know what I'm saying?
I never forget that.
I stopped this guy for like fucking a
week man.
And I finally fucking call them job
early and you know,
I couldn't hear for like two days after
I hit him with that anger.
So you beat him up with a hanger.
I pick them up with a hanger and a
fucking sticks pointing,
stick fighting stick.
You know you have those,
you know like Cali Cali's ticks.
Yeah.
I took one of those.
I put it in my jacket and I whipped them
with the hanger first when they got out
of his car.
And then when he went down I whipped
them in the legs dog.
I pissed my pants.
I had shit in my ass.
Fear is a motherfucker like even when
you're winning,
fear is a motherfucker and I couldn't
hear for two days after what happened to
the dude.
Never came back to work really.
I went back after the holidays and I was
going to get arrested that day because I
did well.
I had the match with the holes.
I did it perfectly.
I throw all the clothes away down in
Glenwood Springs.
I got rid of everything.
You don't want me.
I had this teacher that taught me
everything.
He goes,
if you're going to have blood on your
clothing,
dns sweat,
get rid of everything.
So I had a bag in the car.
I went down valley and got through my
clothes as I went down to eat.
Do you ever go up and down?
80 two.
If you go from glenwood springs up to
Aspen,
that's one of the worst roads in the
country.
I just drew my clothes out of there.
If I was 18,
19,
this guy had to be like 31 bro.
I could smell the fucking.
I was just whipping them at night with
that.
Then I took the stick out and I hit him
in the legs a few times and then I close
to him.
I said,
don't tell him,
listen to nobody who I'll fucking come
back and beat you again and I,
because I didn't want them to hear my
voice.
I went back after the holidays.
He was,
he never came back to work.
The guy sent somebody down to the house
and never came back,
but I was so deaf,
like there's been a couple times that my
hearing has been gone because of
something bad that I've done in the
fucking my heartbeat and the adrenaline
or you hear is like a fucking be well,
most people are just not used to that
kind of confrontation,
you know?
Well the average person,
I mean you just couldn't let him get
away with that.
That little mother Fucker,
you know,
he never saw him again.
After that.
I never saw him again and moved to
everything.
He moved.
I was shitting pickles for a couple of
weeks.
Come get me a note.
Was You?
I don't know really.
I don't know.
I gave him like a three month window
after the knife thing.
I wanted him to say I want him to forget
about it.
Like I was going to do it the right way.
That's how you do it.
Right.
You know?
Wow.
I imagine that was you at 19,
like imagine
like stop.
This was points in your life where you
go.
Was that even really me?
I mean I know it was me because I have
the memory of it.
I know it was my physical body back
then,
but it wasn't really me that was trying
to write the book.
I would read like,
well that those chapters,
I would read it two days later and that
would have to stop Joe Rogan because it
didn't stop.
It didn't stop when I was in high school
or went from Robert Gas station for my
buddy losing $60,000.
Now we had to rob somebody to get the
money that I was on a flight to
Sarasota,
Florida.
The people,
you know,
when I 18 I robbed a jewelry store and I
had to go away.
I got a call one day and then come back.
The guy got it all taken care of.
The guy got,
they didn't arrest you in 60 days,
so he followed the insurance report.
Now they can arrest you,
you know,
like I learned about all those things at
a young age.
Like what a scam.
So the guy knew I robbed them and then
after with a friend of mine told me,
cause yeah,
I bumped into a guy,
the Christmas party,
he was happier,
robbed them.
He goes,
he wanted you to rob him.
He just didn't want you to come back
because then you get arrested and have
to pay restitution.
What can I afford?
$5 a week,
right?
If he cut like seen insurance,
it gets a big lump sum payment.
Plus he could liable what,
what was in there.
So I was doing him a favor.
No Shit.
Fucking crazy.
What you learned and what you learned as
a fucking young.
I was fucked up.
Joe.
Isn't it amazing that you got through it
all though?
That's the really crazy thing.
You got through it all pretty unscathed.
No physical cost me a couple of years in
my life.
Of course,
my daughter asked me two years of my
life that in my early when I got
arrested,
I got arrested for the kidnapping.
Then I had the kid and then I had my
beef with him.
You know,
I had the beef with him when he called
me a Spec and I smacked him and I had
two families already.
They were going to throw me in jail for
fucking him being the guy that was
there.
You're John,
my ex wife and when you have two
felonies,
one more,
but he couldn't in the city of thank God
for Boulder Liberals.
Thank God for Boulder and liberals.
You can't use a racial slur and inside
the city limits of boulder really
because ego because the University of
Colorado,
when that chick called Jj Flanagan the
Nigga and he smacked him and he got away
with it on Monday at court because she
caught on.
So the same thing.
W,
what was that store?
Some white chick was drunk coming out of
a fucking pogo when those 18 and over
bars,
and she got into an argument with Jj
Flanagan and he always tells racist.
Jj Flanagan was a football player at the
time for the University of Colorado.
From that from like 1989 to 93 that a
lot of problems in Colorado that were
getting caught criminals,
but what it was,
it was just three black guys walking
down,
you know,
fucking Boulder at 11:00
at night,
cops pull over.
One of them says racism.
They get into a fight.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
nobody was angels.
That fucking one linebacker the heck and
Davidson Mcgee.
Somebody called him a yom one time.
He punched him in the face so hard.
He broke the guy's eye socket.
That guy ended up going to the fucking
New York giants as a linebacker.
But that's how bad that problem with the
college football players.
It was that bad in boulder at one time.
So when I went to court and the guy
goes,
there's no charges here.
Even the cops wouldn't charge me.
They wrote me a summons to go to court,
but they wouldn't charge me for smacking
the fucking dude.
Then right after that I knew.
You know what,
man,
if I stay here,
I'm going to go to jail.
That's number one.
Number two,
I really wanted to do comedy.
I really wanted to give.
Comedy is shot,
you know,
I was like,
I gotta give it a shot here.
How old were you?
Thirty two years old.
I got on stage the first time.
Nineteen 91.
So how long has that?
Twenty six years,
right?
Yeah,
26 years.
So the first time I dicked around for
the first two years,
but light by 93.
I got really serious about it.
So when I went back to be a dad,
I was really serious about that.
I had a good job,
but they kept fucking with me.
But that one day when he called me a
spic and I smacked him,
that changed everything.
I was like,
that's never going to be the same.
I saw my little girl crying and you
know,
she's a grown up in.
I grew up in that world where people
getting smacked and you know,
I,
she didn't grow up in that,
so I just said,
listen,
I'm never going to win this fucking war.
This is going to be a war that I'm going
to either end up in jail or something
good and I'm going to kill one of these
fucks.
I might as well give company a shot.
What did I have to lose?
It's this crazy thing that that was your
option and then think about all the shit
that you've been through now,
like thinking of yourself back then.
You know,
I mean when you think about today,
like your life with your little daughter
and your wife and you know,
doing podcasts and doing all these shows
everywhere and then just thinking like
holding someone hostage,
kidnapping them,
robin a drug deal with the machine gun.
We just think that was you.
It's,
it's weird because that's not you.
You are not right now.
No,
no,
but you have these memories of things
that you did.
I used a weapon like four times to bust
into drug dealer's house.
She's one of the things that could have
happened.
Oh yeah,
easily.
And the other times I would just rob
them just because I don't give a fuck.
What are you going giving me?
I'm just like thinking about that guy
that pulled the knife on you.
What if after you beat him,
he came back and tried to get you and
then escalated and next thing you know
he stabbed him or he shot him or easily
you could have murdered some.
I was so confused at that time in 1919.
Everybody's confused at 19 but 19 and
been through the shit that you're
confused as I was.
I was really fucking confused.
So I,
I was,
you know,
from I think till 20 something I wanted
to kill my step dad and that was,
what was it?
That was all that was getting consumed
with me like that.
That was my consumption,
like the pain that was going through
without my mom the drugs and killing my
Stepdad,
Stepdad.
But it wasn't about me.
My mom died without a will.
My mom didn't leave a will,
so he took all the money,
all the jewelry.
He didn't give me a piece,
I didn't collect social security,
you know,
uh,
I didn't get my,
my real father died.
My real father was the first Cuban
committee man.
And you didn't city alright.
And he was doing coke in 1966 and
somebody gave him a package and it was
pure heroin.
They'll align to that.
He died,
they took him to the hospital and they
never signed the death certificate in
Union City,
New Jersey.
So they forced
my mother to take him back to Cuba in
1967.
My mom had to take my dad,
my dad's buried and cube.
Wow.
We guess what?
My Dad got an insurance policy and the
debt,
the car,
and I never signed the death
certificate,
so I never got that prudential
insurance.
Plus my mom owned property with Miami
airport is my mom had that property with
200 drug partners where that fucking
thing was.
And I didn't get my cut from that.
So I wanted to kill the guy.
So for years that was my whole thing.
You know,
when I went to Colorado and hooked up
with Fred,
he taught me how to shoot and not a
fucking,
you know,
shoot a fucking rifle and measure
distance and all that shit they do on
TV.
That was me.
What did your step dad say?
Did you ever talk to him?
We ended up talking and shit.
You know what man?
He was the type of person he was and I
wasn't going to get shit and after
awhile I accepted it.
I was like,
you know what?
I'm putting too much stock into this.
Fuck this.
I'm going to go make my own money.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like sometimes we get stuck and I'm
happy I didn't get no money because I
wouldn't have been the person I am
today.
Yeah,
I'm happy I didn't get any money.
And that funding,
that's one of the worst things you can
do is like winning the lottery or get a
big inheritance.
You would think it hasn't been big.
Inheritance would be amazing for you.
It's one of the worst things that can
happen in terms of like your ambition.
If you're in the middle of doing
something,
you've got some ideas or maybe you don't
know what you want to do and you need to
find something,
you're hungry and all of a sudden you
just get a giant chunk of money and
buying things and your ambitions gone.
You don't know what to do.
I don't mind giving somebody start
startup money.
You know you have to give you a child.
Some type of startup money,
son wrong with that,
but I'm talking about like winning the
lottery.
Like people win the lottery.
It's like there's a giant percentage of
them that ruined their life.
Giant.
Like they've done all these studies on
people winning the lottery.
So what is it?
Because I'm giving you a bunch of money.
You didn't earn it like I'm giving you a
bunch of money for sure.
Like think about you and all the money
that you've earned in your life.
You've earned it.
You do all these shows.
You've built up a successful standup
career.
You built up a successful podcasts.
You've done a lot of film and TV.
You've worked,
you've worked right.
You've gathered up and you make a good
living.
Now you know,
but this is all from work,
right?
There's a buildup to it.
It makes sense in your head.
There's an effort.
There's a reward for that effort.
There's motivation,
there's disciplined is focused,
and then there's a payoff for all that.
If you just get the payoff with no
discipline,
no focus,
no lessons learned.
It's just not a healthy way to exist.
It's terrible.
That's why rich kids are so fucked up.
Rich kids that grow up with trust funds
are all fucked.
Not all of them.
A giant percentage of them are thought.
I knew a guy who was a rich guy and his
parents were fucking billionaires
and he grew up with two trust funds.
He burned through his first trust fund,
fuck that up,
and then they had a backup trust fund
for forum.
He was buying houses and flipping them
and losing money and investing in
businesses and they all went under.
He had no discipline,
no understanding of what money really
was and no hunger because he never had a
time in his life when he was poor.
He never had a time in his life where
he's worried about paying the bills and
if you don't have that and you don't
have that real motivation,
I just don't think you ever really
appreciate success.
The people I think that appreciate
success are the people that worked for
it.
You know what?
You could remember back when you were
poor,
like I've had people say to me like,
why do you do so many jobs?
Why do you have so many things you do?
Like,
what?
What?
Why do you keep moving?
Why do you do so much?
Because I remember being scared.
I remember being broke.
I remember having no idea where the fuck
the money was coming from and what my
future was going to be and I was always
terrified of being a loser.
That's that feeling of not succeeding is
what motivates you.
That knowing that you failed in the past
and that you know,
there's been many times where like,
how many times do you bombed and you get
off stage.
You're like,
I can't do this.
I'm not a comedian.
I'm fucking terrible.
Like I got to figure out what the fuck
I'm doing with my life.
If you don't go through those things,
if you don't have those experiences,
if you don't have those moments in your
life where you're unsure of the future,
you're not going to have the real
resolve that it takes to make it the
grit and determination that it takes to
move forward,
and if you don't have that,
any success that you do have,
you're not gonna appreciate.
Nothing comes easy and if it does come
easy,
it's not.
You don't have it.
You don't really have it.
Nothing comes easy so far.
They would never stick with Jujitsu.
If it was a mistake,
I would've quit your job to have because
it's so hard because I would have
thought I wouldn't be able to do it.
Yeah.
Once you try something new,
I can't do this,
but we come.
How fucking scary.
How weird is it that you want to chose a
career that basically for the first two
years when not going to get a dime,
not a dime and no,
no certainty at all.
Nobody understands that.
Nobody understands that,
that that,
that you're not going to get a fucking
job,
and not only that,
there's no pathway.
It's like if you want to be a doctor,
you go to college,
you get a degree,
you go to medical school,
you do your residency.
There's a pathway.
That pathway is.
It's,
it's hard work.
It's very difficult to do.
Not everyone's going to get through it
successfully,
but at least there's a pathway.
What the fuck is the pathway for being a
successful comedian?
Your pathway is different than mine.
Mine's different than Jenkins,
Duncan's or res.
We all have different pathways.
We all have different styles.
We all have different points of view.
We all have different ways.
We deliver material.
We all have different ways of writing.
No one can tell you what to do.
When you first got into this,
did you think of any success?
Honestly,
what did you think the outcome was going
to be?
Because for me,
I thought that that was just going to be
a road comic and if I was an extra in
the movie,
that would be the best I would get.
For me,
that's the honest truth.
Fitzsimmons and I was taught were
talking about this recently goes
fitzsimmons and I started out doing
exactly the same time.
Our number one goal was being a
professional,
like getting paid,
not having a day job.
That was the goal.
Being able to pay your bills.
That was my goal.
That's not having a day job.
I didn't care if I made $80,000,
$200 dollars.
No,
there was no,
no,
no.
There was no like,
I want to buy a mansion or I just want
to be happy,
be happy.
I didn't want a day job and I knew one
other thing.
When I got in that car in June of 95 and
I got on 30th street in boulder and I
headed out on the Irish.
There's a gas station there and that
probably had.
When I took my [inaudible] that I left
on the thing of a triple running.
You know that right?
That's where you left Colorado.
People with triple right.
I met a girl in Michigan that was nasty
little dirty girl,
white girl,
caroline,
and then she came to Colorado.
Threw me a little dose of that monkey
got me all crazy and then she went to
Seattle.
I was having so many problems in Denver
that it just.
There was no listen.
I love my little girl.
I believed that I could have been a good
dad.
It just wasn't going to work.
This was going on,
got this,
was not going to end good.
This and all I kept seeing was that
picture Mickey Rourke at the end of the
fucking angel heart when he's sitting
there smoking a cigarette with a razor
in his hand,
blood all over him.
That's all I kept thinking about.
I go,
you know what,
I'm looking to go to Seattle for the
summer.
Hanging out with this broad.
But in my heart I knew I wasn't going to
come back.
I knew I wasn't going to come back so
much that I had two licenses.
You know,
you buy out,
you know how you lose the license and
then one day you find it and by that
time you've already got licensed.
Yeah.
I must have had like $69 on me when I
left both and I had to get the Ogden,
Utah.
That was my first road.
Greg ever for David Tribble Ogden,
you dot?
I think it was like a 10 hour drive,
maybe longer.
How long have you been doing standup at
that point?
Two years.
So you had started in Denver?
I started in [inaudible] 91 and now it's
95.
But you got to remember from 91 to 93.
That was part like convict.
I sold volumes.
You want to buy coke?
Meet me at the broker.
I saw you a coke when I'm doing 10
minutes.
I didn't write.
I didn't really know anything about
comedy.
I just knew I wanted to be a comic.
I had a business card and I told people
I was going to be a comedian.
I was just lying.
But then I did a stint in New York for
nine months in 93 and that's where I
really got a hint.
I took a standup comedy class.
You ready for this?
The guy took the standup comedy class in
New York Comedy Club in 1993.
I trained with him now with Jujitsu,
really moved to boulder.
He's a comedy writer in town.
First couple times I went in there.
He's my aides.
Will bolt oldest.
Fuck he,
I think he's two years older than me.
He's got white hair and when they I go,
he kept calling himself frank,
frank,
and I'm on top of them and I go,
you fucking leave frank.
I took your writing course.
I never forgot what.
Wow.
You realize why you were rolling with
them while I was rolling with him.
When he told me he was friends with you,
he opened for you at the tree house.
A greenery or something?
Connecticut?
Yeah.
He worked with you up study.
So now what?
Tight.
Now if I see him in Jujitsu,
we talk about comedy and so I took his
stand when I took his stand up comedy
class.
That's when it hit because you said
something that hit home.
He goes,
stand up.
Comedy is how your world collides with
the restaurant world.
Plain and simple and I took that home
and I thought about it.
I'm like,
fuck it makes sense,
and then a week later I wanted to.
Your old triple win.
Let me old triple in that.
Yea old triple m is a fucking dive that
used to do an open mic from midnight to
four in the morning in like alcohol
Ville.
Whereas alcohol bill out of door.
Can you look it up?
It's online but it's closed.
What places in Manhattan?
It's not there anymore.
You'll see it.
Yea.
Old triple in and it did open mics.
The yes,
people fall asleep at 12.
Like I will drive a limo then,
so I will get that equality.
12 sign my name up and the guy would go
three hours.
I got to come back in three hours.
It's midnight.
So I would take the limo,
go to Harlem,
buy a package of coke maybe by refresh.
Then I would go there and do my last
spot for the night.
Lucky old triple and wow,
look at that place or this place.
They had an open mic there from 12 to
four in the morning looking that.
It's crazy,
so I go in at 1:00
PM to 4:00
AM.
Holy Shit,
this is 1993.
I got nothing going on.
I'm depressed.
I'm driving a limo.
I'm snorting coke every night.
I'm living on a little cot and I go in
there when they who's in there bro,
but John Leguizamo
and he's on stage just talking,
but when I was sitting there watching
them,
but I noticed something that there was
eight people in the audience,
but in his world it was massive square
garden like he didn't give a fuck.
Joe Is that when you do a comedy store
late and this six people and people you
got to offer and you're like.
People like that was great.
Pro Show was great because I have may
believe I was at the God.
Yeah,
if you think about six people at the
store,
you're not going to be you.
You can't think about it that way.
You know,
when Paul Mooney,
like when Paul Mooney always intimidated
the shit out of me because I always knew
that he was a writer for prior and he
was like the elder statesman of the
comedy store back in [inaudible] 94 when
I first started there in.
I always had this feeling around him.
Like I was always nervous around him,
you
know,
and when I first started there I was
this young white guy in my twenties.
I wasn't very good,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't get any respect from him,
you know.
And then one day he saw me doing a late
night spot,
like 1:00
in the morning and there was only like
fucking 15,
20 people in the audience.
But I was just doing my best.
I was doing,
I was doing it and,
and I heard the back of the room
laughing.
He was laughing and my shit and then I
got off stage and he came up to me after
the show and he goes,
he goes,
you are a real comic.
He goes,
you did that show.
Like it was a pack motherfucking room.
That's it.
And he goes,
and you killed those people.
He goes,
you killed those people.
you are real motherfucking comment.
And he walked away and I remember
feeling so good.
Like I can't believe Paul Mooney just
gave me a compliment.
Like he told me I was a real comic like
I was in.
And then ever since then give me hugs.
Every time he saw me,
you know,
and this is like,
you get that pat on the back that you
know that thumbs up from someone who you
respect that that means the world.
Man,
that's gigantic.
That's so huge.
I mean when,
when someone does that to you,
that the just the,
the wind in your sails,
it just can take you to a totally
different place because you,
you got the,
you got the stamp,
you know,
you got a stamp of approval from someone
who's real.
Forget
that.
I didn't know the power of the comedy
store like I had.
No,
I read about it.
I heard about it from you and other
people.
I did Miami with Moody with this.
This has to be,
oh baby,
2000,
three,
2004.
And uh,
I opened for him.
You know,
it's a two man show.
It's just me and him at the Miami
Improv.
I'm onstage and I just happened to catch
a fucking,
uh,
I just happened to catch a fucking,
you know,
the energy thing when you just kill it.
Well,
you,
you used to crush the air because you
would do half your punchlines and
Spanish.
I'm killing killing them,
killing them.
But I'm being dirty and I hear the door
open and Paul Mooney.
I could see him walking in and he looks
at me and I'm killing it.
I'm having a good set.
He's killing me,
looking at me.
And he went out in the hallway and the
door was open and he kept yelling to the
staff,
looking at.
I'm like,
fuck,
maybe I'm being too dirty.
Right?
Maybe he's going to complain about me.
How can Paul Mooney complain about?
They taught me this isn't true,
right?
I've been,
I've known him from the store for five
fucking years.
Tommy,
he's not out there going,
I'm too dirty and shit.
But when I got out there,
he hugged me when he came up,
can't keep it going.
What time?
My little brother got off the stage and
I go,
what happened on a.
He was.
He was back there yelling,
fuck the fucking Improv's.
You don't taught him how to be like
that.
That's Mitzi shore by the that.
That's the comedy store.
He was back there yelling that the
comedy store,
you went promise.
You don't develop
deck.
You listened to that.
That's the comedy store.
That's what happens when you hang out at
the comedy store.
That's why that little fat motherfucker
is killing because that's a fucking
comedy store and that you know.
You're right.
That feels tremendous.
One fucking.
He's in your corner.
It feels great.
He's.
He was something special.
He would own the room to Paul Mooney
would sit down.
It didn't matter what time he went up.
Didn't matter how many people in the
audience.
He would sit down.
He had a little tiny bottle of champagne
and he would take his fucking time.
He would take his time.
How crazy is that?
I learned so much from him.
Oh yeah.
How to control a room,
how to control,
not control rule,
meaning like you're a control freak,
but how to get everybody to pay
attention and lock into your thoughts.
Like he didn't try to do a song and a
dance or people look at me,
look at me,
look at me.
He would just command presence with
excellence.
His material was excellent.
His delivery was excellent.
He was calm and composed and you just
always felt like you were trying too
hard.
When you would watch him.
He like,
I gotta figure out a way that he's
doing.
You're right.
That's what he did teach.
Yeah.
Beginning.
You give a fuck.
He didn't give a fuck,
but he licked legitimately didn't give a
fuck.
Boy,
that guy got stole from a lot.
A lot.
Men used to steal all his shit.
Switch out the word Nigger,
put in the word Mexican.
Switch it up about star wars and about
this and about that.
He just.
And you would see the different because
moonee would go on after men see it too,
like been sealed.
Would go on before him and to his shit.
And then moonee would go on afterwards,
you can give a fuck,
just did a shit.
But he knew it.
He would be very frustrated by it,
you know,
he was a,
it was a big influence to a lot of us
that got to see and watch him because we
all knew his history.
I mean,
he was one of the head writers for
arguably the greatest comedian of all
time,
you know?
I mean,
he was one of the feel.
Yeah,
Richard Pryor.
You'd think that I feel it too.
But if there's a big argument or that
argument with the other dude who had all
those specials,
which is I can't think of as George
Carlin's.
Yeah,
I think I can give you the nod.
To me,
it's clear.
It's clear as day.
It's not.
This is not a knock on George Carlin,
who was a great comedian.
He's a great comedian.
George Carlin to me was more of a social
spokesman,
like he was a,
a social commentator and he was a very
great comedian as well.
He had some funny material for sure.
But George Carlin did a special every
year.
Every year.
He did a special and I think,
you know,
his body of work is certainly larger
than anybody else's and he's certainly
one of the all time greats,
but to me there was something about
prior that was just so special and
unique and powerful and just just
resonated.
Man.
I never,
I'll never forget listening to his stuff
when I was a little kid.
Me and my girlfriend in high school,
I think I was like 16.
She was 15 and we were in my room
listening to Richard Pryor on a cassette
and just cry and laugh and sitting on my
bed,
laugh and laugh and,
and I'll never forget.
I'll never forget going to see him.
My parents took me to see live on the
sunset strip when I was like 14 or 13 or
something like that.
I'll never forget being in that movie
theater laughing so fucking hard and
looking around at people like walking
back and forth on their chairs.
And all I remember thinking is,
I can't believe this guy's just talking.
Like I'd seen all these amazing movies
like,
you know,
back to school or stripes or you know,
name the comedy movies that you've seen
all these years.
I saw all these comedy movies that were
great and funny,
but they were never this funny.
Like this guy's just talking.
I'm like,
this has got to be the funniest shit of
all time.
And he's just talking and especially
when.
Yes,
this is 82.
Okay.
So I guess I was 15,
so it's 14 or 15.
That's when it came out was 82,
so I was 15.
So watching this as a teenager,
it planted the seed in my head like,
Holy Shit.
Like how is it possible that this guy
can do this?
That he can just talk and that talking
and just explaining your life
experiences can be so hilarious.
That's the seed that was planted in my
head.
I mean,
I never thought I was going to be a
comedian.
I never,
never had any aspirations.
You know,
my friend,
Dr Steve.
Steve Graham?
Yes.
He just called me.
We just communicated.
I'm still one of my best friends to this
day and will be to the dad died because
that guy is the guy who talked me into
doing comedy.
I was training.
That's when I was competing and I just
loved comedy as a thing.
I just loved comedy and I would always
make fun of people and do like
impressions of people having sex,
like our friends.
Like,
like,
you know,
I would just try to make everybody
laugh,
you know,
and we're all gathered around the locker
room.
Everybody would be nervous before
sparring or everybody be nervous when
we're on our way to fights and
tournaments and stuff like that.
I would be the guy that made everybody
laugh and he pulled me aside and he just
said,
you could be a comedian.
Like you're really funny.
He's like,
you could really do this.
And I said,
I remember saying,
you think I'm funny because you like me.
I go,
other people are gonna think I'm an
asshole.
I say fucked up things.
Like I say fucked up things because I'm
around all these savages.
You know,
I'm around like Leroy Rodriguez and I
had a friend named major battle that was
his name.
His real name was major battle.
He was one of a j dot Kim's black belts,
Larry Jones,
all these guys were savages and they
were just fighters,
you know,
and so I could say fucked up things
around them because they were used to
kick and people in the head and they're
used to fighting and tournaments and
taken,
taken bus trips to go kick the shit out
of people.
I mean that was what they did.
That's what everybody did back then.
So the way I felt about it was like I'm
making a group of very crazy people
laugh.
Like these are like,
we're all misfits,
you know,
we were all like people that didn't fit
in in a normal world because we were
just fighting and I'm like,
they'll laugh because they're crazy and
they're all punching people and kicking
people and this is a different world.
I'm like,
other people are not going to think I'm
funny.
But he talked me into it and so from
there I started writing some stuff down.
I waited about six months until I turned
21.
I went to an open mic and then uh,
after I turned 21,
like maybe,
what is it?
Sixteen days later I went onstage.
I turned 21,
August 11,
1988 and then August 27th I went
onstage.
Wow.
Yeah.
But that was just 100 percent.
Someone telling me to do it 100 percent.
I always loved it.
I used to watch evening at the Improv
and I would always watch stand up on the
tonight show,
but I just loved it like the way I like
music now,
you know,
like I love watching music or listening
to music.
I don't have any talent,
I don't have any aspirations,
but I love,
I just love music.
To me it's just,
it does something to me.
It makes me feel good.
I'm a fan of it,
you know,
I'm a fan of a lot of shit that I'll
never do but stand up.
It was just one of those things like I
just love it
doing it and I would,
you know,
it would just be my number one source of
release as far as like a entertainment.
It's funny that you say that about words
because for me I was listening to the
Beatles with my buddy and he had an
older brother that was a junkie.
That's how I discovered Richard Pryor.
Oh really?
We were listening to the Beatles like I
want to hold.
And then went like,
this is cool.
And his brother came and said,
what the fuck?
You faggots listened to them.
We're like,
we'll listen to the Beatles,
you know,
we're all excited.
And he's like,
take that shit off.
They took this album cover out with a
black dude on it and also they put some
on.
I hear this fucking laughter and I'm
like,
what the fuck is this shit all a sudden
come and kind of say Richard Pryor and
you're like,
and after that first side I was done.
Like once I heard the wine,
Oh,
meets Dracula,
is it something?
I said that's what that was my.
I don't know if it's the niggas crazy.
Why don't meet Dracula.
I don't know what I'm exactly a to
track.
It's something I said or the Nigga is
crazy.
Those are the two ounces.
I don't know which one.
When I heard the last cut on it,
which is the wine.
Oh,
meets Dracula.
I was hooked.
I left it.
I bought the album.
I brought it home that I bought
bicentennial Nigga and there's a friend
of my
ray Canelo who I still talk to her.
He was a vp of a Scifi and he goes,
do you still remember coming home?
My house in the sixth grade and your
mother catching this listening to his
mother and I wasn't allowed in the
house.
He goes,
don't you remember that shit?
We used to have a band.
I used to be a singer in this band in
sixth grade,
a canal,
a dealer and John Bender.
What kind of music?
The Beatles.
I want to hold your hand.
Help.
I need somebody.
Yeah,
the Niggas put that nigger's crazy.
Look at the title.
They put like an asterisk where the eye
is like,
what the fuck is wrong with people,
but meanwhile it says it on the album,
like they have the picture where you see
him on the album and it says Nig,
g,
e,
r,
but then they have the actual title for
sale.
What's the website?
This was LP.
Oh,
that's an LP.
You can get that in final.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
Look at that face to young then man.
He's like in his thirties.
God,
he was good.
See to me it's like I have,
this is my version of um,
my,
like evolutionary charter comedy.
I think the guy who started it all off
is lenny bruce.
We too.
So I have Lenny Bruce posters framed on
my wall.
I mean like I just feel like I don't
like,
I don't enjoy watching him or listening
to him as much because I don't think he
was as good today because I think that
the culture was so different back then
that it's not,
it's very difficult for us to,
to sing like the things that he's saying
or not groundbreaking today because he
already broke that ground.
And then the culture shifted with it.
I mean it's not just him,
but a lot of other people,
a lot of other authors and politicians,
all these different people broke
different ground and culture's evolved
since then.
But I think Richard Pryor took what he
did and the honesty that lenny bruce
exhibited on stage and he brought it to
the next level.
You know,
he took it to a new place.
And I think that,
that,
that happens a lot when people are
influenced by other people.
I think that's one of the things that's
really important,
the distinction between being influenced
and stealing,
you know,
I think we all influenced each other and
I know you guys influenced me like Ari
and Dunkin and you and all of us
together.
You know,
Tom,
Bert,
we influenced each other and we inspire
each other and that when you see someone
do really good stuff,
like you want to do more,
bird does it to me,
you know,
Louis,
you see someone doing really what
Chappelle,
you see really good comedy,
you want to do more really good comedy
and everyone's sort of influencing
everybody.
So I think that honesty that Lenny Bruce
expressed was so unique for the time,
if there was no one had ever done any
sort of social commentary in,
in,
in a,
in a comedy form,
the way that lenny had done so.
And then Richard Pryor took it and just
blew it out of the water.
I mean,
Richard Pryor was raised in brothels.
He was raised in a brothel.
Joe,
he was raised in a whorehouse in Peoria,
Illinois.
I mean,
Richard Pryor was experiencing life in a
different way,
you know,
in all his experiences with drugs and
craziness and wild people growing up.
And then,
you know,
the comedy of the time shifting from the
sixties into the seventies,
it became this thing that he was at the
forefront of.
And in my opinion,
he's like the most revolutionary figure
in all comedy.
He's,
he,
he was just so different and so unique
and so polished.
You know,
I remember I was,
uh,
I was living with my roommates and like,
because it was like 87 or something like
that.
We had this place in,
in revere.
We're all living together.
Wasn't malted Malt,
whatever the fuck we were were living
in.
Oh No,
it was Lynn,
Lynn,
Massachusetts near the beach and we all
watched a Sam Kennison special,
which was hilarious.
It was really funny.
But then we watched prior,
after we watched Kennison and we were
like,
wow,
look how much smoother prior is like.
That's what I remember thinking and I
remember my friend bill,
he goes,
look how much more black polished he is.
I'm like,
that's the word,
right?
It's like polished.
He's like,
yeah,
he's like smooth there.
He was smoother.
He just had a,
a different sort of style.
Whereas kinison was just kinison was
just kickstart and everything and just
fucking knock it.
I was going to see him coming,
but let me.
What's his name?
What's the Lenny Bruce?
Lenny.
Bruce.
I don't think his materials outrageous,
but I liked this cadence.
Yeah,
man.
You do it man.
So I told the guy,
listen,
he's got some jokes that hold up.
Listen to them.
Come back in a little while too,
because he said the word slut.
I don't know if you build to Wordsmith,
say snap is a great word because he's
lovable and I like how they shot his
specials.
I like how they shot him.
I like,
I like that black and white.
Somebody just gave me one of the towns.
Gave me him live from Carnegie Hall.
It's got.
Wow.
After a while you sit.
There you go.
Should I shoot myself?
But there's a couple pieces in there.
Will you see it man?
I read that book that led.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's a book that a great book to.
What about the hotel in New York and how
he.
Oh yeah,
he did jazz music,
you know,
shooting heroin all day,
hanging out with aluminum foil on the
window.
The windows have a copy of that.
Ladies and gentlemen,
let me boil that shit.
I love all this shit.
That's what made me become a jail.
Bring it up,
baby.
Drink my wife still look good.
Standing up against this thing.
The,
the lowest.
I really put her down.
No,
no.
I really met her.
I don't want some shock chick.
The can code and work with boys.
I just want to hear my lady say,
get up and fix this thing.
It still making noise all along.
All along.
What the fuck is this?
He was just doing weird shout out.
He was,
he has a joke today.
It still holds up gay people.
He goes to say homosexuals.
He goes,
they lock him up in jail for being gay
where they put them in there with a
bunch of men who want to have sex with
them.
Give you some volume on this.
Well,
Elizabeth Hale a be combined Mitzvah'd
no
is continuity.
I'll behave myself.
I'll do all the lines where he hurts,
you know that the thing,
you know,
I have a reputation for being sort of
controversial and irreverent and also
the semantic bed trap of bed tape.
And actually I do have an.
I will always be accused of bad taste by
the people who eat in her service,
you know,
that kind of scene to anyone yet.
But you might be interested in how I
became offensive.
Started in school with um,
uh,
drinking.
And uh,
I was really,
I was like,
get real depressed kid.
Seven,
eight years old.
And I really get juiced and get out of
so the teacher would really get bugged
me singing and carrying on calling
Columbus of thing again.
And who's being Arand bar and then
smoking.
I don't know if you can,
can you see that from him?
I've got like,
I'm the 10th to hear fix your teeth.
I,
uh,
see I smoked Marlboros and that's six
years old and I grew up there.
The funny thing is that it's the mantic.
There are words that offend me.
Uh,
let's see.
Governor faubus segregation offend me.
Uh,
a nighttime television offends me.
Some nighttime.
The show is that exploit homosexuality,
narcotics and prostitution under the
guides of helping these societal problem
in the,
except for a few shows.
There's one guy on the coast who's got
like a sense of,
you may know his name is Paul Coats.
And he found out there were kids that
eight and nine years old that was
snipping airplane glue.
You get high on,
you know,
and uh,
I had sort of a fantasy how it happened.
The kid is alone in his room and it's
Saturday,
the child is played by George mccready
to know him in the room and Saturday
mothers away and wouldn't lie to you.
That's good.
In hostels and led to the aisle.
I'll make an airplane.
That's good.
It's hard to like.
You know what I'm saying?
It doesn't really translate today
because we're just.
This was irreverent and crazy back then,
but today we're like,
hmm.
Very interesting.
He was getting.
He was doing his thing.
It's historic.
Right?
So you're watching this and you're
hearing people laugh and you've got to
put your.
It's,
it's impossible to enjoy this without
understanding the context of the time
that he was doing it.
Like you have to Kinda like put yourself
at the time were all this was taking
place.
Whereas I think prior stuff's still
translates today.
You know,
there's a lot of prior material that
you'll watch today and you'll still
laugh your ass off.
Stuff of him going back to Africa,
stuff of him shooting his car because
his girlfriend's trying to leave.
So he shot the car.
Like he's got some,
some bits that are still to this day,
like,
and you know,
he massively influenced Eddie Murphy.
Massively influenced Chris rock who was
influenced by Eddie Murphy.
You know what I mean?
He,
I think he's the cornerstone.
I think he's the big cornerstone.
Stand up.
I'm happy to say I feel the same way.
I thought that you will go to.
I liked George Karl.
I think George Carlin's,
I'm sure,
but he wasn't my Richard Pryor.
Richard Pryor,
right?
My fucking belt.
I love for me.
For me it was prior and then it was
Kennison after prior.
Like Kenneth,
I think kinison for a couple of years
was just a monster monster.
Now they be,
oh,
special.
The lighter.
What's the name of that lie from?
Hell?
That's louder than hell.
Fucking tremendous.
I mean,
listen,
the Isis first special.
Oh yeah.
It's a fucking thing.
There's some specials for the.
Just they hold it.
I used to watch when I used to go to
that for they used to be a movie rental
place on Twenty Eighth Street in
Boulder.
It was three floors.
It was the biggest video store on the
west coast 20 years ago.
They had everything I rented that Rodney
special from them so much.
And it.
What else?
I rented the best bet for Joe Torry.
Joe,
sorry.
Joe.
Tory was the warmup then before,
but when he had.
No,
no,
because in those days.
Yeah.
What's his name was the host of the show
for def jam before he,
who was the host of def jam,
um,
who's smart and for awhile already did
it.
They used to have jumped toi.
Was Jack back then remember that he
would do like sleeveless shirts.
You'd have giant ass fucking arms.
He was in that mood with Janet Jackson.
Yes.
That's when he was young with Tupac and
fuck in
uh,
the Janet Jackson is Mexican boyfriend
CV.
Yeah.
Some pictures of video of Joe Torry host
in Def Jam.
Like with,
he would wear a sleeveless shirts,
like nobody ever dressed like that.
And he was funny.
He was funny bro.
I liked that one.
He has that guy been.
I just flew with him a couple of weeks
ago where he still lives here.
He has his house in St Louis.
He's got a house.
He's raising this kid and guy torry
started that fat Tuesday's right.
That was the thing that was at the
comedy store.
Fucking great guys.
But he's fucking amazing.
There's Joe.
See if you can find a picture of him
right down there.
Nothing really popped.
It doesn't show anything.
Did he?
Was Jack Jack like unusually Jack for
comedians.
It doesn't show him on stage with like
sleeveless shirts and shit.
Well that's Martin Lawrence.
Martin Lawrence banned.
That guy was my nemesis.
Not,
not in a bad sense,
but in that I would have to go on after
him all the time the crime was started.
Oh my God.
Mitzi shore put me on after him 50
fucking times.
Those were some of the 50 hardest sets I
ever had,
like doing standup in the early days,
I would just fucking bomb.
Just like the Hindenburg just go down in
flames.
It's okay.
Jammer.
I never really saw him at the store.
Oh Man.
He was so good.
I caught him,
but it was before your time.
This was like when I first started,
so I was at the store when I first got
passed in [inaudible] 94,
so this was like around 94 95 before you
came along and he was on fire.
Martin Lawrence was on fire and he
people forgot how God damn good he is
because he went crazy and he had all
those issues and you know,
he,
he's wearing a rubber suit and he had a
gun.
They got pulled over and he said he was
dehydrated and it was on some sort of
drugs and they locked him up in a psych
ward.
Like there's a lot of nutty shit with
him.
Right.
So people forgot how God damn good he
was when he was in his prime.
But when he was in his prime,
yeah,
there he is and bad boys.
But that's not the price.
That's the stand up though was what was
up when I saw him at the comedy store
and he would wear fucking like leather
jumpsuits and shit and just rip that
place apart.
He was on fire and he was another one
that had a bunch of jokes that people
have decided were offensive when MTV was
getting upset at dice clay.
Remember when they banned dice clay for
offensive material?
I believe he got caught up in a
controversy about offensive material to.
It's like the early days of political
correctness.
They decided to get pissed at certain
jokes.
The other day I was driving.
I was thinking about news radio.
You're so crazy.
You motherfucking hide.
Not Horshack Epstein.
The play your brother Apollo.
I was just 16.
Nick Depaulo and Brian Cowen.
Oh my God.
Where did you pull up?
Epstein?
Well,
they hired Epstein,
but Nick Depalo and Brian Cowen I
brought in.
Okay.
I thought High Epstein to.
Yeah.
No,
no,
I don't.
I didn't meet him until he was on the
set.
He was a real nice guy though.
Did he pass away?
Oh,
thanks.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I check it.
I feel like was really fucking sick,
bro.
Your buddy,
the one guy who introduced me to from
that baseball show you on the Spanish
guy that was on there with your nice
guy.
Spanish guy.
Yeah.
You were on a baseball show?
Well,
I'm thinking Mike Star.
Mike Star who uh,
the Spanish guy that came to visit at
the store a few times.
He's a guy.
Yeah.
I just donated to his gold.
There's a dude from star trek.
Remember that?
That dude,
it's in star trek all the time.
I'm fucking.
What is his name?
God Damn it.
But he was the older pitcher and I was
the young asshole ballplayer.
What was that?
Betty White?
Yeah.
She was not betty.
What was it?
Betty White?
No,
the other lady from,
uh,
what's the cast?
Some.
God Damn it.
I don't remember her name.
See if you can find the cast.
Yeah,
but you don't want images that you want
actual text.
Don't go to images.
Sometimes it pops up.
Wow.
See?
Yeah.
Ben.
Rosemary.
Yeah.
Rosemarie.
Ben Greenwood.
Mike Star.
Keep going.
Scrolling left.
Yeah.
Ben Greenwood.
He thought guys and star.
He's in a bunch of movies now.
Dan Flores.
He was in a law and order law and order,
but go the other way that doing
wentworth.
She's hilarious.
She's been in a bunch of shit.
Chris Browning,
he was on.
He's been a bunch of signs attic.
He recently.
Was He Mike fucking weird man.
What year was that?
What year is it?
Say it was four.
Four,
four.
That's when I had to move to California.
I was miserable.
I was shooting this the first couple of
weeks we'll get me.
I was like 26.
There are so weird.
Um,
you know what,
man,
when,
when it first started out it was fun.
And then,
um,
what happened was with twitch TV shows,
a lot of times you have like these
really funny writers and these guys who
wrote it originally were really good,
but the,
uh,
they had written from married with
children and the simpsons and the
network had decided for some reason they
weren't strong enough to run the show
and that they were only writers.
They weren't like a real show runner.
So they brought in.
This guy was a show runner.
He was terrible and I didn't get along
with him at all and they were actually
close to firing me or him
like there was like a real impasse
between the two of us because the guys
riding was dog shit.
I was crazy back then.
Did I didn't give a fuck.
I had zero filter.
I never thought I was going to be an
actor in the first place.
I couldn't believe him on the set.
And so they would try to get me to do
stuff and it'd be like,
what?
And they would like give me the script.
Like wow,
we made revisions to the script and I
would read it goes this fucking terrible
and they would get pissed at me and
people will be pissed.
I'm going to tell me how this is funny.
Explain to me how this is funny.
And then you know,
like executives are going,
you know,
you're talking to my agent,
this guy,
you know,
he's,
he's very arrogant and he's causing
problems on the set and I'm like,
I'm not causing problems in the set.
I go,
they took the writer stuff,
they rewrote it and they turned it into
dog shit,
you show me,
show me how it's not,
and I was like very close to like
killing my sitcom career completely just
by having no filter,
but then they realized it,
they read it and then they came and
watched some of the run throughs and the
network fired him,
but it was close.
He wanted me out,
but I was one of the stars of the show.
It was me and Ben Greenwood Guy,
but.
And then I mean it was a,
it was an ensemble show,
but I played the star player.
There was,
there was about a baseball team of
fucked up baseball team and I was the
guy who was always causing trouble and
wrecking his car and going crazy and so
they were having a real problem with me,
but it was,
it was because these guys that had
originally wrote it,
these guys were genius.
They were really,
really funny and they took their words
and just butchered it and turned into
some hackneyed fucked up sitcoms,
which is what they usually do.
Well,
Jim Brewer was in the pilot with me,
Jim Brewer.
That was me look like a baby.
So weird.
Um,
so jim brewer was in the pilot with me.
He played the mascot for the team.
Fuck.
It was funny man.
And Jim and I were buddies from New
York.
There's Jim that's Jim Breuer.
No,
Jim Breuer played the pioneer who uh,
he had like the,
the bay I feel like,
like he got in a fight.
Jeff current and Kevin Martin back back
that up right there where you see the
lens of the screen where you see the
words like right there.
Kevin Curran Rather.
And Jeff Martin,
sorry I fucked her.
Name's up Kevin Kern and Jeff Martin
with the guys who,
who wrote it and um,
they were really,
really nice guys and we really funny
guys but they were writers,
you know,
and this was something that they'd
created and then the network just
butchered it.
And then it wound up getting canceled
and then I was ready to move back to New
York,
but I fucked up.
But I had already got a lease on an
apartment.
I got an apartment on Moore Park and
studio city,
or it was actually north Hollywood and I
was like,
fuck,
already got this apartment,
like what do I do?
And so I'm like,
God,
I got to stay here because I got a
lease.
And I was like,
shit,
I want to move back to New York.
I hated it out here.
I hated dealing with actors.
I'd never been around actors and that
thing that,
that we were talking about before where
people just say things that they don't
really mean because they think that
you're supposed to say those things
because there's like a pattern of
behavior that you chose to.
Yeah,
I thought he was amazing in that film.
It was excellent.
I thought he had a lot to offer.
I mean there was a lot of that kind of
nonsense out here where I was used to
real people.
I mean,
for sure I was a flawed person.
I mean for sure.
I was rough and I said I just wasn't,
didn't have good decorum.
Like the way I communicated,
I was a rough guy,
you know,
I'd come from fighting and then went
right into standing up and this was only
a few years later I'm doing this now.
I had my last fight in 89,
so this is 94.
I mean this is just a few years after
that I was still very sketchy,
you know,
so I didn't belong.
I felt like I didn't belong there.
I felt like I couldn't be myself.
Everybody was like reading the Hollywood
reporter and variety,
unsettling the fuck you guys reading
this shit for like,
it's like this.
It was just the whole thing to me was
like this weird play that people were
putting on where everybody was trying to
pretend to be something so that they can
get auditions.
And I remember going on some auditions
and dealing with some of those people,
casting agents that had all this power
over you and they,
they exhibited it like they exerted it
when you were in the room with them.
They didn't communicate with you like
you're a person and I'm a person.
They communicated with you like you want
something from me and I don't know if
I'm going to give it to you.
Hmm.
Let me see what you do.
It was just the way they did.
It was just so shitty.
It was just.
It was gross.
It was fun.
Oh,
it's gross.
I mean this is.
This is the thing that people have.
The real problem that people have with
this.
However Harvey Weinstein situation is
not just that the fact that he was a
piece of shit to all these women,
it's his position of power that he had
over them that he exerted.
He got himself into this position and
then use that position to on some.
I mean,
according to Whitney Whitney.
Cummings was talking to me about this.
She's like,
what you're hearing as all the women
that said no to him.
She's like that guy.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck the economy.
And it was part of the deals that he
gave and they even went after one of the
girls.
He was fucking that girl from Donnie
Brasco and she did the movie with the
Gretchen Mol.
Yeah,
she did.
Rounders,
oh,
I remember the blonde cute thing.
Now if you watched Donnie Brasco,
she,
Donnie Brasco,
she ain't got a fucking line to that.
More.
Not Aligned.
Willing.
She's an extra in that movie.
Basically Sonny black girlfriend,
but when you see her in fucking
whatever,
she's got a bunch of lines now and it
was because she was fucking highway.
They just went after a couple of weeks
ago.
Gretchen Maga who went and met,
who went after just,
you know,
Angelina Jolie and the truth.
Oh,
they're all saying that this is the
reason why dick suck suckers.
Listen,
they all got to suck it up virtually.
Look,
I had heard that there was a lot of them
that were actually very successful that
fucked him.
I mean this was this,
this guy's thing.
It's,
it's Kinda,
it's.
I mean it's fucked up and it's dark.
But once that gets going and once that's
what he does,
how do you stop that train?
Other than what they did,
they all knew.
They all knew and nobody opened their
fucking mouth.
So you could suck my dick.
A couple of them opened them out.
A couple of them get,
they got swept under the carpet and
that's always gonna happen,
but I rather fucking,
you know,
the rest of these like Angelica and the
rest of these people.
Listen,
I'm over brother.
I don't want to hear this shit no more.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing,
like just the bullshit that these people
create in their worlds and you're right,
when you go to these casting things and
you see these things,
you see the fucking bullshit at out of a
man.
Well,
it's one of the reasons why people in
this town are so crazy.
It's because their insecurity to begin
with,
right?
The only reason why anybody becomes an
actor,
like why,
why people want to be famous,
not the only reason,
but one of the main reasons why people
want to be famous is because at some
point in their life they didn't feel
valuable.
At some point in their life,
they felt discarded.
They felt abused,
they felt ignored and they had this
inescapable need for attention.
This,
this whole that cannot be filled,
and that was the driving force that led
them into acting.
Where would they could be on that stage
and everyone was looking at them all
eyes on them while the microphone was on
and the words were coming out of their
mouth and they were in the play or in
the movie or doing stand up even.
It's a lot of the same stuff that
propelled you and I being ignored as a
child,
you know,
like p feeling like you were nothing.
And then realizing that when you're on
stage man,
then your something like that person up
there with a spotlight on them,
that person's shining.
That's a something person that's not a
zero,
but that thing that leads you to become
an actor want to become famous is also
like it's,
it's so fucked up with acting because
you have to get chosen.
It's not like music or like stand up
where you can look at,
stand up.
All you have to do as you do open mic
nights,
you get funny,
you build up an act in and people come
to see you.
You build up a career and the next thing
you know you,
you become a successful comedian.
That's what happened to you.
That's what happened to me,
but with acting,
you have to get chosen.
You don't.
You don't have to work like if you do
plays,
nobody is ever going to fucking see you
ever.
You're never gonna make it out of place.
Nobody's going to see famous play
actors.
Nobody gives a shit about them.
You have to be in movies,
you have to be in television,
so you have to get chosen,
so you have this whole chain of like
June,
maybe I'll pick you,
but I'm not sure are you the one?
And so you have to develop this sort of
personality that fits in with their what
they're looking for.
You have to mold your sensibilities and
your ideas.
Like there's a lot of people that are in
Hollywood that don't have opinions of
their own.
What they have is a series of opinions
that they've adopted,
adapted
because they think it's going to lead
them to be successful.
Have they heard of star?
But you know how many times I go to an
audition,
I hear this like my.
This is my.
A lot of people don't like to audition.
I like to audition and I'll tell you why
because I fuck with them because you're
funny.
You know,
I ripped my pants,
you know,
if you watch,
uh,
what's that show on CBS?
That's been forever.
Don't fudge one Monday night's Big Bang
theory.
The one before that.
How I met your mother.
I didn't know how I met your mother.
I didn't even know you did it.
Yeah.
If you watch the episode,
you're like,
Joey,
you're an extra.
I'm an extra.
You know why?
Because I want them to the audition.
I had no underwear on and there was
this.
You see these things that pop out of
chairs.
Yeah.
Side things are missed and she goes,
get up to read.
When I,
when I got up to read the fucking thing,
you got caught in the hole in my pants
and my dick came out.
All three women sat down and I go to use
the egg roll and then I lost them for
sure.
They even told me they go,
you got the job.
As I was walking down the street on Fox,
my phone rang,
my angel goes,
go back.
You didn't even read.
I didn't even read it.
They had called.
My agent said,
we love this guy.
I went back and they saw the Cuban.
They grow,
you know,
probably not used to someone with
confidence that didn't give a fuck.
You know,
I went to an audition one time,
Bro,
where the guy had never forget this.
The guy was a white trash guy,
like this family moved in,
there was a pilot for ABC and this guy
is one of those guys that he had a
little circular pool in front of his
house and he was,
he was watering shit,
but at the same time he had like a thug
and he's fat,
he's got jewelry.
I'm like,
well,
those guys are like long island.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'll never forget.
I get to the audition.
All these guys are there.
Tony Lago.
God rest his soul.
He's Big Italian dudes.
And I knew they were going to get the
park bro.
I'm like,
they're going to get the part.
I'm not going to get it.
But I had warm up on it.
Alright.
I a warm up sign with the string and I
had white tidy whities and that zip up
jacket and I had a way three 80.
So I walked in,
I go,
I know what I'm going do.
I'm to take my pants off,
I'm taking my walk in.
And what do you think these two ladies
say to me?
I hold on one second,
we'll be with you in a minute.
So they turn around.
That's my cue,
bitch.
I took those sweat pants off.
I took the shoes off and my socks and I
walked closer and I took my shirt off.
When they turned back around,
all I had was boxer shorts on like the
tidy whities that's it.
Tits hanging out,
stomach hanging over the underwear.
And then as soon as they turn it around
and they're like,
oh my God,
that is terrible.
I'm like,
I'm not putting on shit.
Right.
I'm reading this motherfucker.
So you were supposed to like wave and
say good morning.
And they're like,
action.
I love it.
And they like
can't even look at me because I'm
completely making it,
you know?
And they can't even look at me that I'm
making believe I'm flipping burgers and
like look over at him.
I go live in like a doctor.
They booked me.
When I got to the audition,
that was the read live in like a doctor.
They even gave my own line.
Those dishes I wanted to.
They gave you whatever line I said in
the audition,
like whatever they said wasn't good
enough.
I go in there with my own fucking line.
Yeah,
that's,
that's probably why you got it.
Look,
look,
look and show where he's just sitting.
That's when you were in those big daddy
shirts.
Look how big I was.
Jesus Christ.
You were enormous back then.
Must have been like,
what?
Two thousand nine,
right?
Yeah.
This is 2000,
2002 when I met you,
like right after my chair brought you
onto the set of news radio and they were
all like,
whoa.
Who is this guy with the leather jacket
on?
Because this guy,
your friend like Joey,
they didn't know by the way that's
looking at the red comes out of your.
But by the way,
every time you call me,
that's what comes up.
I call me right now.
Call me
watches.
Hilarious.
That's us in the pool in Austin,
Texas.
When we were doing cap city.
You,
me it,
Ari.
We're doing cap city and.
Oh,
tate was there.
Oh yeah,
that's the old days.
Do you know how to call me,
please?
This is why I got a new phone.
This is why I got to get a new phone
because there's a.
let's get out of here.
Joey.
It's 2:15.
I don't want you to get stuck in
traffic.
No,
I'm good.
I love you guys tonight in the store.
No,
I got the.
I got to fucking ballet thing.
I got a dinner and I got to trick the
trunk.
What are you doing?
Um,
November first.
What is November?
Wednesday.
Next Wednesday.
November first.
You want to do the Ice House?
No,
I'm doing it.
You're doing what?
Podcast.
Oh,
you do podcasts at night?
Move that shit.
Can't do them with the daytime failing.
I always end up canceling and people
cancel on me.
It's podcasts on Tuesday or some shit.
I do this week.
I have to do Sunday and Wednesday.
Oh,
you have to?
Yeah,
I'm leaving Thursday.
How about a Sunday and Tuesday?
What do you mean?
Do the Ice House on Wednesday when you
do some.
Because I scheduled this guy for he go
and do Wednesday.
Are you're doing wheeler?
Wheeler,
Walker.
He's come back.
He can move around Tuesday.
He's doing.
He's doing some type of tourist.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
He's killing it out there.
Then the following week,
I'm only in town Monday and Tuesday
because I got to leave to New York on
Wednesday for the fucking festival,
so I get back from Omaha Sunday.
I'm just doing one past Monday and Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
I love you.
Don't forget all behind the Brassica
next week,
bitches and the week after that Gotham
comedy club with deem del Rizzy.
Run a bunch of us,
the New York comedy festival.
Come on out,
bitches.
Thank you for being legit.
Where's the beats that over here?
Let's get outta here.
I gotTa Piss real quick.
Ran Out the door.
Bye everybody.